sagt katarina barley herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
und an dieser stelle geben wir ab in den
deutschen bundestag dort findet heute
die generaldebatte da ab die
generaldebatte stadt und mein kollege
gerd joachim von fallois beobachtet das
ganze für uns
ja vielen dank die generaldebatte in
haushalts wochen immer am mittwoch ist
ja der zentrale tag da geht es um die
politik der bundesregierung in gänze und
der oppositionschef wird die debatte
eröffnen darauf dann der bundeskanzler
antworten ein schlagabtausch der auf
vier stunden angesetzt ist und der heute
sicherlich besonders interessant wird
denn die neue ampel regierung hat von
anfang an eigentlich nur agieren können
die ereignisse haben sich überschlagen
spätestens seit dem 24 februar den
angriff der russen auf die ukraine ist
nichts mehr so wie vorher sie haben es
mitbekommen dass große 65 milliarden
paket wird sicherlich eine entscheidende
rolle spielen aber auch die
energiepolitik da gibt es ja ganz
aktuelle entscheidung darüber will ich
reden mit meinen beiden heutigen gästen
ich begrüße ganz herzlich waren es vogel
den stellvertretenden parteivorsitzenden
der fdp und auch der erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer seiner
fraktion und die part der
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
hervor ich habs gerade gesagt ihr
fraktionschef herr dürr hat nach der
entscheidung von robert habeck was die
kkws angeht gesagt so geht das nicht wir
können nicht die atomkraftwerke
abklemmen und der strompreis wird immer
weiter steigen der bundeskanzler wird
heute sicherlich auch sich auf die seite
von robert habeck stellen damit es ist
entschieden zwei koalitionspartner sind
für diese regelung zwei kraftwerke in
reserve zu halten die fdp es massiv
dagegen hat sogar präsidiumsbeschluss
wie geht es jetzt weiter ja wir erleben
doch sowieso dass wir uns daran gewöhnen
müssen dass wir unterschiedliche
parteien haben die eine koalition bilden
und die auch ihre unterschiedlichen
positionen darstellen dürfen wenn am
ende der debatte gutes ergebnis für das
land rauskommt und ich finde das haben
wir jetzt beim entlastungspaket gesehen
dass ein gutes ergebnis herauskam dass
wir gemeinsam einen großen wurf machen
wollten und jetzt diskutieren wir über
die frage wie sieht strommarkt aus ich
kann nur für mich sagen es macht es hat
auch für mich zb die wirtschaftsweisen
veronika grimm lag gestern noch mal und
die letzten tage noch mal sehr deutlich
gemacht es macht in dieser lage wo wir
ein problem haben mit versorgung je nach
szenario und wo wir auch ein problem
haben mit viel zu hohen strompreisen
macht es keinen sinn sichere und
klimaneutrale kraftwerke vom netz zu
nehmen und deshalb werden wir das noch
ausdiskutieren müssen aber wenn zwei
koalitionspartner sagen das macht sinn
aus ideologischen gründen bei denen
grünen sicherlich dann kann doch die fdp
nichts mehr ausrichten oder wird es noch
ein koalitionsausschuss geben werden sie
noch versuchen diesen beschluss zu
kippen oder ist das jetzt fakt naja es
folgt ja in jedem fall aus dem vorschlag
des bundes wirtschafts und
energieminister die veränderung die
notwendigkeit gesetze zu verändern muss
als atomgesetz kann oder ein anderes
gesetz als atomgesetz kann das heißt wir
werden hier diskutieren müssen man
braucht eine mehrheit und uns geht es um
die sache es geht doch hier nicht um ihr
geht es nicht um ideologie oder
irgendwelche profilierungs fragen
sondern wir sind in einer schweren
energiekrise ganz offensichtlich haben
wir nicht nur ein gas sondern auch ein
stromproblem und dann mussten müssen wir
doch darüber sprechen was können wir
dagegen tun und in meinen augen sind sie
kapazität von drei kernkraftwerken auf
jeden fall etwas die ich mir nicht
dauerhaft wünsche aber die wir jetzt in
dieser schwierigen zeit in den nächsten
monaten noch weiter betreiben müssen
alles andere ist doch einfach nicht
vernünftig weil das auswirkung hat
natürlich auf versorgungssicherheit aber
ja auch mit dem einfluss dann auf die
gaskraftwerke die dann den preis am
strommarkt setzen auf das
durchschnittliche preisniveau und da
haben wir offensichtlich ein problem und
wenn es offensichtlich ein blick auf die
vernunft gesprächsbedarf gibt dann
müssen wir auch weiter darüber reden
aber hat viel lachen so nett die linke
ist ja auch für das auslaufen der akw es
die lösung dieser herr
ballon er habe da präsentiert erwartet
ist die denn sinnvoll denn es wurde mal
ausgerechnet das wird mindestens 45
millionen kosten die am netz zu halten
aber sie werden keinen strom liefern ist
das ein sinnvolles verfahren schauen sie
die stimme zu dass wir ein strom und ein
energieproblem und ein gas problem haben
sowohl was die versorgung als auch was
den preis betrifft ich finde das hier
eine regelung gefunden worden ist die
vor allen dingen dafür sorgen soll dass
die grüne basis die entscheidung des
novembers dass man nämlich weiter am
netz bleibt schlucken kann das ist doch
der kern es geht um den frieden in der
ampel und es geht überhaupt nicht darum
wie rational entschieden werden kann da
kann man ja unterschiedliche sichten
habe ich kenne die der fdp für weiter
betrieben das ist zulässig aber was
jetzt gemacht wird ist um den frieden in
der ampel wie beim entlastungspaket es
wird für jeden etwas gemacht und völlig
aus dem blick geraten die menschen die
den riesen sorgen sind das ist das was
ich auch der ampel beim entlastungspaket
vorwerfe es wird riesig aufgebläht also
verbal und wenn man mal real hinschaut
dann ist das vielfach völlig
unzureichend fiel nur das thema
kindergeld erwähnen 18 euro weil wir
haben acht prozent inflation noch das
wären zehn prozent und dann gibt es 18
euro am ersten januar die inflation ist
jetzt das ist für all diejenigen und nur
diesen einen punkt zu nennen völlig
unzureichend und bei den atomkraftwerken
ist dass friede der ampel und nicht etwa
ein sach problem da kann man dann
entscheiden das hätte man tun können
auslaufen punkt oder wegen meiner auf
verlängerung was ich nicht teile aber
diese art und weise der grünen basis
eine brücke zu bauen dass man dann im
november wegen der schwierigen lage
müssen sie weiterlaufen das geht so
nicht neben der ampel ist ja die frage
die fdp sehr unzufrieden und sie könnte
noch unzufriedener werden herr vogel
denn herbert schafft es gerade
angesprochen das kindergeld da gab es
auch massiv kritik von friedrich merz
und der union das wird jetzt
nachgebessert da wird für das dritte
kind jetzt auch drauf gelegt dann ist
heute morgen von frau mass zu hören der
parlamentarischen geschäftsführerin der
spd das wahrscheinlich noch ein weiteres
paket folgen muss auch ihr
parteivorsitzender und finanzminister
hat in einem großen interview gesagt
also wir versuchen alles aber wenn es
nicht anders geht dann müssen wir noch
mal nachlegen das würde ja auch bedeuten
wahrscheinlich dass die schuldenbremse
nicht zu halten ist und der mittelstand
hat sich heute auch massiv beschwert hat
gesagt wir sind ihnen dieser
regierungskoalition gar nicht mehr
vertreten unsere interessen werden da
nicht wahrgenommen da hat auch robert
habeck gestern abend noch mal erklärt
wir werden für die auch noch was tun da
kommt riesig viel auf sie zu
wahrscheinlich für die schuldenbremse
nicht zu halten sein vorbild nein wir
sind doch in einer doppelten krise wir
sind in der energiekrise und wir haben
eine inflation die immer heftiger wird
und ja auch sich von den energiepreisen
in die sogenannte kerninflation rein
frisst und wenn sie dann darüber reden
und mit klugen
wirtschaftswissenschaftler sprechen was
ist in zeiten der inflation zu tun dann
ist es nicht schuldenfinanzierte
ausgabenprogramme zu machen weil das
belastet die menschen und das frisst den
menschen eben auch das einkommen weg und
deshalb ist diese situation so
herausfordernd und ich glaube genau
gerade deshalb ist es auch fatal wenn
wir jetzt so mit den klassischen
kategorien darüber reden gibt es kleine
positions- unterschiede der parteien
geht es um frieden oder um streit darum
geht es nicht sondern wir sind einer
absoluten ausnahmesituation dürfen
übrigens auch kurz noch mal festhalten
wo die herkommen dass wir so schlecht
vorbereitet in dieser situation zum
beispiel energiepolitik als land sind
das sind langfristige energiepolitische
fehlentscheidung der letzten jahre 1000
das lernen für die lehren für die
zukunft langfristig zu denken aber die
ursache von all dem ist eine einzige
allein nicht wladimir putin und das was
er sich wünscht dass wir jetzt in
interne konflikte als gesellschaft uns
begeben das sollte mir den gefallen
sollten wir ihnen nicht tun und ich
glaube dass das entlastungspaket eines
ist was bei der entlastung steuerlichen
entlastung der breiten mitte war es bei
der gezielten weiteren unterstützung
gerade von kleinen einkommen ganz ganze
menge schafft die frage der
energiepreise die ist eine die wir
ergänzend leisten müssen und deswegen
ist es entlastungspaket ja nicht nur
eins was finanziell entlastet sondern
gehen wir auch an strommarkt design ran
weil wir eine ausnahme situation sind
das fällt niemandem leicht aber das ist
notwendig und deswegen müssen wir auch
an die frage wann wieviel wo kommt denn
die energie her wo kommt denn das
angebot her und darüber haben wir gerade
gesprochen und dann müssen wir mit blick
auf die sache da sehe ich anders als die
opposition ist legitim dass die
opposition kritische fragen stellt ist
auch legitim dass die linkspartei immer
sagt ich könnte noch mehr sein das in
ihre klassische rolle aber wir müssen
agieren am ende mit einer vernünftigen
lösung das gebietet die lage in dem fall
hat das mehr geld gar nicht die
opposition zwar gefordert aber
mittlerweile ja schon ein
regierungsvertreter zugesagt wie robert
habe das für den mittelstand noch was
passiert ja beide wirtschaftshilfen muss
was passieren es muss was passieren bei
den energiepreisen das ja auch klar
verabredet das ist jetzt erst der blick
nach europa weil die eu kommission etwas
angekündigt hat und wenn die nicht ganz
kurzfristig agiert dann agieren wir und
generell bleiben wir handlungsfähig in
schwieriger lage jederzeit reagieren 65
milliarden ist eine menge sie haben das
scheinriese genannt und zwar weil
eigentlich das geld ja sozusagen die
koalition durch die situation eigentlich
ein nimmt noch einmal dass wenn man sich
nur die einnahmen aus der mehrwertsteuer
an schaut wenn das bis zum jahresende 50
bis 60 milliarden sein und 65 milliarden
ist sehr sehr viel geld gar keine frage
erstens muss man erwähnen dass einen
relevanten teil die länder tragen werden
und dann will ich mal einmal dagegen
stellen das sind eine nacht entscheidung
der bundeskanzler mitgeteilt hat 100
milliarden sondervermögen was auch
nichts anderes als schulden sind aber
damit man die schuldenbremse einhält
wird das so gemacht würde ich nicht noch
einmal darlegen dass gegenüber nach und
hier werden 65 milliarden als ein
riesenpaket verkauft wenn man sich
anschaut was schon vorher klar war da
alles mit eingerechnet worden und es
gibt so große weiße flecken man mich
wundert dass ein vertreter der fdp
gerade bei den wirtschafts hilfen nicht
sagt er selbstverständlich ist hier viel
zu wenig getan und selbstverständlich
brauchen wir ein weiteres
entlastungspaket das hört sich auch mal
so an wie entlasten erstmals belastet
worden das wird das problem derzeit man
muss sich doch nur angucken wie viele
insolvenzen ist die bibel arbeitsplätze
das kostet ich höre nur
horrornachrichten gerade auch aus den
neuen ländern und da muss man etwas tun
da kann ich sagen ach eigentlich sind
wir schon ganz schön toll und die
koalition hält zusammen nein es stimmt
ja völlig richtig wir haben eine
multiple krise und der putins krieg
dieser furchtbare angriffskrieg
russlands hat das alles verschärft aber
wer dann sagt es der alleinige grund ist
einfach nicht wahr die energiekrise die
inflation war vorher bereits hoch wir
hatten vorher bereits ein
versorgungsproblem die ganze frage klima
die spielt jetzt keine rolle mehr das
geht jetzt wegen jahren herrn vogel
sondern eher an die grünen dass 1,5 grad
ziel ja das können wir irgendwie in den
wind schreiben also diese vielen krisen
da erwarte ich dass wir in einer
gemeinsamen kraftanstrengung natürlich
die regierung aber bitte auch unter
aufnahme der hinweise der opposition
agieren weil wir haben sonst eine
situation dass wir einen wirklich heißen
herbst bekommen der soziale frieden in
unserem land ist gefährdet man muss sich
mit den menschen unterhalten die
wirklich am monatsende schon lange kein
geld mehr haben und da muss gehandelt
werden das ist meine feste überzeugung
wir zumindest werden weiter druck machen
dass ein viertes entlastungspaket wie
immer man das nennen
dieser haushalt der hier behandelt wird
ist letztlich makulatur es muss alles
neu gemacht werden dass das aber
wirklich die verluste ausgleich das muss
bringt nur trümmer seien für das ist
kann ihn die von herrn barth in dieser
sekunde vom mast hat das heute morgen
auch unterfüttert ist wird neue pakete
geben müssen schätzungsweise denn allein
die arbeitslosigkeit über die hat noch
überhaupt keiner gesprochen den letzten
wochen und monate die wird jetzt
galoppieren zu nehmen alleine da wird
der bundesfinanzminister schon nach
nürnberg viel mehr geld überweisen
müssen sie werden doch daran nicht
vorbei kommen wir wissen doch die
doppelte krise verantwortungsbewusst
bewältigen und das heißt wir haben die
krise bei energie werden die
notwendigkeit gezielt zu entlasten und
wir haben die krise bei inflation das
belastet die bürger mittelfristig auch
am schärfsten wenn sich das rein frisst
so und da müssen wir verantwortung
bewusst agieren das geht wenn wir uns
die lage anschauen und opposition und
regierung vielleicht gemeinsam
verantwortungsvoll agieren dann wäre das
gut das geht aber ganz sicher nicht
dadurch dass die opposition in den
klassischen modus verfällt immer zu
sagen höher schneller weiter und vor
allem dinge gegeneinander ausspielt also
100 milliarden entlastungen sind jetzt
dieses jahr auf dem weg und natürlich
mussten die 100 milliarden in die hand
nehmen um die bundeswehr handlungsfähig
zu machen weil wir einen krieg in europa
haben und dann mir putin nicht in der
ukraine zwingend halt macht wenn man
ihnen nicht einhalt gebietet so also das
gegeneinander ausspielen so in die
klassischen reflexe verfallen das
überzeugt mich nicht zielgenau zu
entlasten und auch breit und mit einem
kräftigen paket zu entlasten ist ja
genau was wir seit wochen im sommer
diskutiert haben was wir jetzt tun und
jetzt mal gucken welche elemente fehlen
noch aber das gegeneinander wenn ich das
sagen darf dass wir deshalb schon nicht
funktionieren weil nur für die
nachfolgeregelung dass neun euro tickets
wie immer sie denn aussehen mag da sehr
offen wenn sie die zustimmung im
bundesrat brauchen das ist nur ein punkt
verloren haben und stein geht entweder
entweder sie kriegen das so hin dass sie
das auch mit den oppositionsparteien
machen die auch regierungsverantwortung
tragen wie in vier ländern die union
viel mehr oder es wird nichts deswegen
kann ich nur raten hier nicht zu sagen
auch die ampel schon klasse und nur ihr
seid die ewigen nörgler und wollte mehr
nein es geht um qualitative dinge sie
haben vom sprungbrett lieber kollege
maxim aber dann brauchen sie doch keine
strohmänner damit das dritte mal gesagt
was ich angeblich gesagt habe was ich
vor gar nicht gesagt habe lassen wir
doch das ritualisierte und analysten
welche ausnahme lage dieser saarlands
unterschritten das erkenne ich an so er
möchte ich gerne an haken in die
ausnahme die leute angst die leute
möchten auch dass es knapp werden wird
die politiker sagen es sind ja auch das
wird ein ganz schwieriger herbst werden
und da geht die linke nun hin und ruft
die menschen auf die straße zu gehen mit
dem motto heißer herbst gegen soziale
kälte und was eigentlich für sie noch
schlimmer wiegen mag ist dass sie sich
im grunde um da an die seite der rechten
gegeben die nämlich teilweise mit ihnen
auf dem gleichen platz am wochenende
demonstriert haben und die afg hatte
fast den gleichen slogan heißer herbst
statt kalte füße kommen sie da nicht
eine ganz komische ecke also erstens
demonstrieren wir nicht mit rechten
gemeinsam wir haben doch kein
abgrenzungsprobleme das versuchen
diejenigen die diesen protest
denunzieren wollen und ich sage ganz
klar wir brauchen beide ist die
auseinandersetzung in den parlamenten
aber bitte auch den protest auf der
straße weil nur der wird dazu führen und
das haben wir gesehen wie so gibt es
denn 300 euro jetzt auch für
rentnerinnen und rentner wieso gibt es
das für studierende ich habe vor monaten
noch gehört wie alle schlauer erklärt
haben wir richtig das ist jetzt auf
einmal ist diese entscheidung richtig
sehr gut habe ich kann nur sagen der
druck der straße bei entscheidend wie
beim neuen euro ticket beides ist
notwendig damit sich die regierung
bewegt und wir haben keinen
abgrenzungsprobleme rechts hat mit uns
nichts zu tun punkt meiner vielen dank
ich muss ein bisschen abkürzen sie
müssen dringend rein vielen dank jetzt
wird hier die nächsten vier stunden
darüber weiterdiskutiert die beiden
herren wollen pünktlich sitzen denn es
gibt jetzt einen debatten punkt der
vorher so noch nicht vorgesehen war
michael gorbatschow ist ja vergangene
woche verstorben und habe bars die
bundestagspräsidentin wird jetzt hier am
anfang seiner gedenken der ehrenbürger
berlins der friedensnobelpreisträger von
1990 hier am deutschen bundestag da
wehen die flaggen auf halbmast und
dieser mann wird hier heute jetzt vom
deutschen parlament geehrt werden der
herr bundespräsident hat gibt sich
ebenfalls die ehre auf der
besuchertribüne und ich gebe rein ins
parlament
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen eröffnet
die sitzung
sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir trauern um herrn michael
sergejewitsch gorbatschow der am
dreißigsten august verstorben ist
präsident gorbatschow war ein mann des
friedens
er veränderte die welt zum besseren
er machte möglich was über jahrzehnte
undenkbar schienen den kalten krieg
friedlich zu beenden und die teilung
unseres landes und unseres kontinents zu
überwinden
wir deutschen haben michael gorbatschow
viel zu verdanken
er hat die geschichte unseres landes und
das leben von millionen menschen
verändert
sein mut und seine haltung waren
entscheidend für die wiedererlangung
unserer staatlichen einheit diesen
einzigartigen und großen moment unserer
geschichte das werden wir nicht
vergessen
er war wegbereiter der wiedervereinigung
mit seinem unverhofften aufbruch in eine
neue politik hatte den menschen in der
ddr mut gemacht sich selbst zu
ermächtigen
glasnost und perestroika
warum sollte das nicht auch in der ddr
möglich sein
auch sein besuch in ost-berlin im
oktober
1989 zum vierzigsten starts jubiläum der
ddr trug dazu bei dass die deutschen in
der ddr gegen die sed diktatur
aufbegehrt
als frauen und männer
1989 in immer größerer zahl in plauen in
leipzig in ostberlin in dresden in
schwerin in magdeburg und an vielen
anderen orten in der ddr auf die straße
ging fragten sich viele werden wieder
panzer rollen
doch die sowjetischen soldaten blieben
in ihren kasernen
das ende der ddr und die deutsche
wiedervereinigung
erfolgten friedlich
die us amerikanische publizistin
applebaum schrieb ich zitiere
gorbatschows radikalste handlung war der
verzicht auf gewalt zitat ende
gorbatschow versuchte letztlich nicht
das sowjet imperium mit militärischer
gewalt oder nuklearen drohungen zusammen
zu halten oder sich selbst mit gewalt
an die macht zu klammern
seine politik des erklärten
gewaltverzichts und seine aufgabe des
moskauer herrschaftsanspruchs gegen den
gegenüber den satelliten staaten stärken
die bürgerrechtsbewegung in mittel und
osteuropa seine entscheidung führten zur
freiheit für viele millionen menschen
michael gorbatschow selbst sagte dazu
1999 zehn jahre nach dem mauerfall hier
an diesem rednerpult und ich zitiere ihn
die tatsache dass die wiedervereinigung
gerade damals und gerade auf diese art
und weise stattgefunden hat ist ein
verdienst der völker selbst zitat ende
die warschauer pakt staaten sollten
selbst über ihren weg entscheiden können
1989 und 1990 respektierte gorbatschow
ausdrücklich das selbstbestimmungsrecht
der völker
der kalte krieg ist zu ende verkündete
im dezember 1989 bei seinem treffen mit
us präsident george bush vor malta
bei seinem gipfeltreffen mit helmut kohl
im nordkaukasus im sommer 1990 stimmte
er auch der nato mitgliedschaft des
künftigen wiedervereinigten deutschlands
zu
am ende eines von zwei weltkriegen der
block konfrontation und der nuklearen
abschreckung geprägten jahrhunderts
erlebten viren einen friedlichen wandel
der auf mich oder
auch der für mich ehrlicherweise im
historischen rückblick ein ganz großes
glück war
insbesondere für unser land ein glück
für dass wir michael gorbatschow dankbar
bleiben werden
[Applaus]
mit seiner versöhnungsbereitschaft
leistete unschätzbares für die
historische aussöhnung zwischen
deutschen und russen die frage nach den
künftigen
deutsch-sowjetischen beziehungen
bewegten ihn wie auch 1990 immer wieder
an helmut kohl schrieb und auch wir in
deutschland haben uns eine
vertrauensvolle partnerschaft mit
russland gewünscht
ich sage mit großem bedauern dass eine
partnerschaft mit russland derzeit nicht
möglich ist
gorbatschow bezeichnete vertrauen als
den wichtigsten faktor in der
weltpolitik
mit vertrauen veränderte er die welt
sein vertrauen zu bundeskanzler kohl und
auch zu deutschland öffneten den weg zur
einheit unseres landes und für mich war
er einer der großen vertrauens stifter
des vergangenen jahrhunderts
dialog und vertrauen das war die
grundlage seines politischen handelns er
hatte den mut
eingefahrene wege zu verlassen die sich
als sackgasse erwiesen
er baute vertrauen auf zu es präsident
reagan und ersetzte vertrauen an die
stelle von abschreckung und
konfrontationen und das war eine
radikale kursänderung
dieses vertrauen wuchs auch als
gorbatschow von kompromissen sprachen
diese vokabel hatte man vorher selten
aus moskau gehört so brach er ausweglos
erscheinende konflikte auf
gorbatschow brachte neues denken in den
kreml er suchte die abkehr vom
gleichgewicht des nuklearen schreckens
mit dem emf vertrag über die vernichtung
der atomaren mittelstreckenwaffen leute
zu gorbatschow und reagan
1987 das ende des nuklearen wettrüstens
zwischen den großmächten ein
mit der abrüstung wurde
weg zum friedlichen ende des kalten
krieges bereitet nach vier jahrzehnten
ost-west-konfrontation in europa
für seine abrüstungspolitik und für
seinen neuen weg in der außenpolitik
erhielt gorbatschow
1990 den friedensnobelpreis
als gorbatschow
1985 an der an die spitze der
sowjetunion aufstieg befand sich das
land bereits im niedergang
seine bürgerinnen und bürger lebten in
resignation
gorbatschow wollte mit reformen das
leben der sowjetbürger verbessern den
sozialismus weiterentwickeln ihm ein
menschliches antlitz geben er wollte die
angst in der beziehung zwischen dem volk
und der staatsführung ersetzen durch
dialog
auf einmal mischte sich dieser junge
staatsmann bei seiner ersten dienstreise
in das damalige leningrad unters volk er
fragte die menschen nach ihren sorgen
und problemen und er versprach
änderungen seine offenheit und sein
aktives werden um die bevölkerung waren
gar geradezu unerhört hatte doch das
volk in angst vor der macht gelebt und
die macht in angst vor dem volk
glasnost und perestroika ging in die
internationale sprache ein
die neuen freiheiten wirkten grosse
hoffnungen nun konnte man in der
sowjetunion freisprechen ohne haftbefehl
zu müssen sogar über die verbrechen des
stalinismus und den gulag wurde
gesprochen archive wurden geöffnet neue
zeitungen bücher erinnerungen erschienen
doch den niedergang des kolonialen
imperiums konnte gorbatschow nicht mehr
aufhalten
die sowjetunion war nicht mehr
reformierbar
gorbatschow der schritt für schritt
vorgehen wollte endlich die kontrolle
über sein eigenes land im august 1991
wurde gegen ihn geputscht die völker der
sowjetunion
strebt nach freiheit
und unabhängigkeit
am 25 dezember 1991 löste sich die
sowjetunion auf
es gibt wohl wenige politiker die in
deutschland so fair so viel verehrt
wurden wie er
und wir werden ihn als großen freiheits
geber in erinnerung behalten
die sehr unterschiedlichen reaktionen in
russland mittel und osteuropa und auch
in deutschland nach seinem tod zeigen
nicht nur die vielschichtigkeit seines
wirkens sie zeugen auch von
grundlegenden missverständnissen und der
tragik seines politischen lebens
er wurde einsam im eigenen land
in russland werden ihm der zerfall des
sowjetimperiums und die not der
neunzigerjahre angelastet er litt unter
dieser entfremdung von seinem eigenen
volk
im südkaukasus und im baltikum erinnert
man sich schmerzhaft an das brutale
vorgehen gegen friedliche
demonstrationen 1989 in tiflis den
schwarzen januar 1990 in aserbaidschan
und dem blutsonntag von vilnius 1991
während seiner amtszeit
es fand später trotz aller bewunderung
und dankbarkeit auch eine gewisse
entfremdung mit dem westen statt
etwa in der bewertung der russischen
außenpolitik von putin
gorbatschow war vom westen durchaus auch
enttäuscht er machte sich aber dabei
nicht leicht er zog sich nicht zurück
sondern engagierte sich weiter
gorbatschows verdienste um das ende des
kalten krieges und die wiedervereinigung
unseres landes und unseres kontinents
bleiben einzigartig
die unterschiedlichen reaktionen zeigen
aber wie rainer feser in der faz
vergangene woche anmerkte welche
missverständnisse und enttäuschungen
seit jahren zwischen russland und dem
westen bestehen
gerade wir deutschen haben zu lange
gorbatschow streben nach verständigung
frieden und partnerschaft als grundlage
unserer beziehungen mit russland
vorausgesetzt dabei haben wir übersehen
oder vielleicht auch nicht wahrhaben
wollen dass sich russland unter putin
längst und radikal von gorbatschows
zielen abgewandt hatte
die entwicklung in seiner heimat
besorgte gorbatschow er rief die
regierenden in russland auf keine angst
vor den menschen zu haben und auch ihre
freiheit nicht zu unterdrücken
gleichzeitig setzte er vertrauen in die
russische zivilgesellschaft
besonders in die jungen menschen
russlands zukunft kann nur demokratie
bedeuten schrieb er 2009 10
gorbatschow war trotz aller rückschläge
und defizite zutiefst davon überzeugt
dass es letztlich kein zurück zur
totalitären vergangenheit geben er war
sich sicher dass nur eine demokratische
entwicklung seinem land eine zukunft
bieten kann
vor wenigen jahren sagte michael
gorbatschow in einem interview interview
wir wollten die mauern des misstrauens
zwischen ost und west seitigen überhaupt
jede mauer zwischen staaten zwischen
völkern zwischen menschen zitat ende
zwischen russland und europa kraft heute
ein tiefer graben dort wo nach
gorbatschows vision ein gemeinsames
europäisches haus entstehen sollte
mit russland und mit einer gemeinsamen
sicherheitsarchitektur
im juni 1990 schrieb er an helmut kohl
dass die überwindung des blogs systems
und die gestaltung neuer
sicherheitsstrukturen im
gesamteuropäischen geiste zu suchen sein
es ist russland das unter putin mit
diesem geist gebrochen hat und das ist
ein tragischer fehler
es ist russland das die ukraine angreift
und mit waffengewalt die europäische
friedensordnung zerstört
gorbatschow war ein mann des friedens
als kind hatte er den zweiten weltkrieg
erlebt und er wollte die welt von ihrer
größten bedrohung befreien immer wieder
mahnte er zur atomaren abrüstung und
warnte eindringlich vor der gefahr eines
neuen krieges
eine neuerliche konfrontation russlands
mit den westen blieb bis zuletzt seine
größte sorge
michael gorbatschow stand für
gewaltverzicht für freiheit und für die
selbstbestimmung der völker er stand für
eine weltordnung in der staaten durch
dialog und auf grundlage des rechts
konflikte beilegen und gemeinsamen
lösungen für globale probleme suchen
es schmerzt uns zutiefst dass alles
wofür er stand heute auf so eklatanter
weise verletzt und zerstört wird
gorbatschows mut kann uns aber auch in
diesen dunklen stunden
zuversicht vermitteln für die großen
herausforderungen vor denen wir jetzt
stehen er war humanist
er glaubte an die menschen und ihre
möglichkeiten
man kann wenn man will betonte er immer
wieder
selbst unter schwierigen bedingungen
lassen sich so meinte er neue lösungen
im interesse der welten gemeinschaft
finden man darf nicht aufgeben und sein
handeln war das beste beispiel dafür
[Applaus]
die welt muss nicht bleiben wie sie ist
auch nicht nach diesem brutalen krieg
den russland gegen die ukraine führt es
kann ein besseres morgen ein besseres
übermorgen geben aber der weg dahin wird
sicherlich lang und auch steinig wir
brauchen mutige menschen die für eine
friedliche gerechte und nachhaltige welt
bereit sind risiken einzugehen und
eingetretene pfade zu verlassen
die bereit sind neu zu denken und zu
handeln
politiker und persönlichkeiten wie
michael
gorbatschow
mit ihm verliert das deutsche volk einen
treuen freund
ich verneige mich vor dem großen welt
verändere und dem großartigen menschen
ich möchte sie jetzt bitten sich als
zeichen des respekts unserer dankbarkeit
und unserer trauer in gedenken an
michael gorbatschow von den plätzen zu
erheben für eine schweigeminute
ich danke ihm bitte nehmen sie wieder
platz
wir unterbrechen die sitzung jetzt und
werden um 39 mit der sitzung
fortfahren herzlichen dank
ja meine damen und herren so weit dass
wirklich würde vor der gedenken an
michael gorbatschow durch die bundestags
präsidentin bärbel
bas ja und wir werden an dieser stelle
hier die kleine unterbrechung nutzen um
ihnen noch mal das interview an zu
spielen was ich heute morgen geführt
habe mit johannes vogel und dietmar
bartsch
ich begrüße ganz herzlich johannes vogel
den stellvertretenden parteivorsitzenden
der fdp und auch der erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer seiner
fraktion und die part der
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
hervor ich hab es gab gesagt ihr
fraktionschef herr dürr hat nach der
entscheidung von robert habeck was die
pkws angeht gesagt so geht das nicht wir
können nicht die atomkraftwerke
abklemmen und der strompreis wird immer
weiter steigen der bundeskanzler wird
heute sicherlich auch sich auf die seite
von robert habeck stellen damit es ist
entschieden zwei koalitionspartner sind
für diese regelung zwei kraftwerke in
reserve zu halten die fdp es massiv
dagegen hat sogar präsidiumsbeschluss
wir geben das jetzt weiter ja wir
erleben doch sowieso dass wir uns daran
gewöhnen müssen dass wir
unterschiedliche parteien haben die eine
koalition bilden und die auch ihre
unterschiedlichen positionen darstellen
dürfen wenn am ende der debatte gutes
ergebnis für das land rauskommt und ich
finde das haben wir jetzt beim
entlastungspaket gesehen dass ein gutes
ergebnis herauskam dass wir gemeinsam
den großen wurf machen wollten und jetzt
diskutieren wir über die frage wie sie
es am strommarkt aus ich kann nur für
mich sagen es macht es hat auch für
nicht zum beispiel die wirtschaftsweisen
veronika grimm lag gestern noch mal und
die letzten tage noch mal sehr deutlich
gemacht es macht in dieser lage wo wir
ein problem haben mit versorgung je nach
szenario und wo wir auch ein problem
haben mit viel zu hohen strompreisen
macht es keinen sinn sichere und
klimaneutrale kraftwerke vom netz zu
nehmen und deshalb werden wir das noch
ausdiskutieren müssen aber wenn zwei
koalitionspartner sagen das macht sinn
aus ideologischen gründen bei den grünen
sicherlich dann kann doch die fdp nichts
mehr ausrichten oder wird es noch im
koalitionsausschuss geben werden sie
noch versuchen diesen beschluss zu
kippen oder ist das jetzt fakt naja es
folgt ja in jedem fall aus dem vorschlag
des bundes wirtschafts und
energieminister die veränderung die
notwendigkeit gesetze zu verändern muss
ans atomgesetz kann oder wer ein anderes
gesetz das atomgesetz das heißt wir
werden hier diskutieren müssen man
braucht eine mehrheit und uns geht es um
die sache es geht doch hier nicht um mir
geht es nicht um ideologie oder
irgendwelche profilierungs fragen
sondern wir sind in einer schweren
energiekrise
ganz offensichtlich haben wir nicht nur
ein gas sondern auch ein stromproblem
und dann mussten müssen sie doch darüber
sprechen was können wir dagegen tun und
in meinen augen sind sie kapazität von
drei kernkraftwerken
auf jeden fall etwas die ich mir nicht
dauerhaft wünsche aber die wir jetzt in
dieser schwierigen zeit in den nächsten
monaten noch weiter betreiben müssen
alles andere ist doch einfach nicht
vernünftig weil das auswirkung hat
natürlich auf versorgungssicherheit aber
ja auch mit dem einfluss dann auf die
gaskraftwerke die dann den preis am
strommarkt setzen auf das
durchschnittliche preisniveau und da
haben wir offensichtlich ein problem und
wenn es offensichtlich ein blick auf die
vernunft gesprächsbedarf gibt dann
müssen wir auch weiterhin verwahrt sie
lachen so nett die linke ist ja auch für
das auslaufen der akw es die lösung
dieser herr barth jetzt ballon habe da
präsentiert erwartet ist die denn
sinnvoll denn es wurde mal ausgerechnet
das wird mindestens 45 millionen kosten
die am netz zu halten aber sie werden
keinen strom liefern ist das ein
sinnvolles verfahren schauen sie die
stimme zu dass wir ein strom und ein
energieproblem und ein gas problem haben
sowohl was die versorgung als auch was
den preis betrifft ich finde das hier
eine regelung gefunden worden ist die
vor allen dingen dafür sorgen soll dass
die grüne basis die entscheidung des
novembers dass man nämlich weiter am
netz bleibt schlucken kann das ist doch
der kern es geht um den frieden in der
ampel und es geht überhaupt nicht darum
wie rational entschieden werden kann da
kann man ja unterschiedliche sichten
habe ich kenne die der fdp für weiter
betrieben das ist zulässig aber was
jetzt gemacht wird ist um den frieden in
der ampel wie beim entlastungspaket es
wird für jeden etwas gemacht und völlig
aus dem blick geraten die menschen die
den riesen sorgen sind das ist das was
ich auch der ampel beim entlastungspaket
vorwerfe es wird riesig aufgebläht also
verbal und wenn man mal real hinschaut
dann ist das vielfach völlig
unzureichend ich will nur das thema
kindergeld erwähnen 18 euro weil wir
haben acht prozent inflation noch das
wären zehn prozent und dann gibt es 18
euro am ersten januar die inflation ist
jetzt das ist für all diejenigen und nur
diesen einen punkt zu nennen völlig
unzureichend und bei den atomkraftwerken
ist dass friede der ampel und nicht etwa
einfach problem da kann man dann
entscheiden das hätte man tun können
auslaufen punkt oder wegen meiner auch
verlängerung was ich nicht teile aber
diese art und weise der grünen basis
eine brücke zu bauen dass man dann im
november wegen der schwierigen lage
müssen sie weiterlaufen das geht so
nicht neben der ampel ist ja die frage
die fdp sehr unzufrieden und sie könnte
noch unzufriedener werden herr vogel
denn herbert schötz gerade angesprochen
das kindergeld da gab es auch massiv
kritik von friedrich merz und der union
das wird jetzt nachgebessert da wird für
das dritte kind jetzt auch drauf gelegt
dann ist heute morgen von frau mass zu
hören der parlamentarischen
geschäftsführerin der spd das
wahrscheinlich noch ein weiteres paket
folgen muss auch ihr parteivorsitzender
und finanzminister hat in einem großen
interview gesagt also wir versuchen
alles aber wenn es nicht anders geht
dann müssen wir noch mal nachlegen das
würde ja auch bedeuten wahrscheinlich
dass die schuldenbremse nicht zu halten
ist und der mittelstand hat sich heute
auch massiv beschwert hat gesagt wir
sind ihnen dieser regierungskoalition
gar nicht mehr vertreten unsere
interessen werden da nicht wahrgenommen
da hat auch robert habe gestern abend
noch mal erklärt wir werden für die auch
noch was tun da kommt riesig viel auf
sie zu wahrscheinlich für die
schuldenbremse nicht zu halten sein
vorbild nein wir sind doch in einer
doppelten krise wir sind in der
energiekrise und wir haben eine
inflation die immer heftiger wird und ja
auch sich von den energiepreisen in die
sogenannte kerninflation rein frisst und
wenn sie dann darüber reden und mit
klugen wirtschaftswissenschaftler
sprechen was ist in zeiten der inflation
zu tun dann ist es nicht
schuldenfinanzierte ausgabenprogramme zu
machen weil das belastet die menschen
und das frisst den menschen eben auch
das einkommen weg und deshalb ist diese
situation so herausfordernd und ich
glaube genau gerade deshalb ist es auch
fatal wenn wir jetzt so mit den
klassischen kategorien darüber reden
gibt es kleine positions- unterschiede
der parteien geht es um frieden oder um
streit darum geht es nicht sondern wir
sind einer absoluten ausnahmesituation
dürfen übrigens auch kurz noch mal
festhalten wo die herkommen dass wir so
schlecht vorbereitet in dieser situation
zum beispiel energiepolitik als land
sind das sind langfristige
energiepolitische fehlentscheidung der
letzten jahre 1000 sie das lernen für
die lehren für die zukunft langfristig
zu denken aber die ursache von all dem
ist eine einzige alleinig wladimir putin
und das was er sich wünscht dass wir
jetzt in interne konflikte als
gesellschaft uns begeben das soll mir
den gefallen sollten wir ihnen nicht tun
und ich glaube dass das entlastungspaket
eines ist was bei der entlastung
steuerlichen entlastung der breiten
mitte war es bei der gezielten weiteren
unterstützung gerade von kleinen
einkommen in ganz ganze menge schafft
die frage der energiepreise die ist eine
die wir ergänzend leisten müssen und
deswegen ist das entlastungspaket ja
nicht nur eins was finanziell entlastet
sondern geben wir auch an strommarkt
design ran weil wir eine ausnahme
situation sind das fällt niemandem
leicht aber das ist notwendig und
deswegen müssen wir auch an die frage
wann wieviel wo kommt denn die energie
her wo kommt denn das angebot her und
darüber haben wir gerade gesprochen und
dann müssen wir mit blick auf die sache
da sehe ich anders als die opposition
ist legitim dass die opposition
kritische fragen stellt ist auch legitim
dass die linkspartei immer sagt ich
könnte noch mehr sein das in ihre
klassische rolle aber wir müssen agieren
am ende mit einer vernünftigen lösung
das gebietet die lage in dem fall hat
das mehr geld gar nicht die opposition
zwar gefordert aber mittlerweile ja
schon ein regierungsvertreter zugesagt
wie robert habe das für den mittelstand
noch was passiert ja beide
wirtschaftshilfen muss was passieren es
muss was passieren bei den
energiepreisen das ja auch klar
verabredet das ist jetzt erst der blick
nach europa weil die eu kommission etwas
angekündigt hat und wenn die nicht ganz
kurzfristig agiert dann agieren wir und
generell bleiben wir handlungsfähig in
schwieriger lage jederzeit reagieren 65
milliarden ist eine menge sie haben das
scheinriese genannt und zwar weil
eigentlich das geld ja sozusagen die
koalition durch die situation eigentlich
einnimmt ja einmal dass wenn man sich
nur die einnahmen aus der mehrwertsteuer
an schaut wenn das bis zum jahresende 50
bis 60 milliarden sein und 65 milliarden
ist sehr sehr viel geld gar keine frage
erstens muss man erwähnen dass einen
relevanten teil die länder tragen werden
und dann will ich mal einmal dagegen
stellen das in einer nacht entscheidung
der bundeskanzler mitgeteilt hat 100
milliarden sondervermögen was auch
nichts anderes als schulden sind aber
damit man die schuldenbremse einhält
wird das so gemacht würde ich nicht noch
einmal darlegen dass gegenüber nach und
hier werden 65 milliarden als ein
riesenpaket verkauft wenn man sich
anschaut was schon vorher klar war da
alles mit rein gerechnet worden und es
gibt so große weiße flecken man mich
wundert dass und vertreter der fdp
gerade bei den wirtschafts hilfen nicht
sagt er selbstverständlich ist hier viel
zu wenig getan und selbstverständlich
brauchen wir ein weiteres
entlastungspaket das hört sich auch mal
so an wie entlasten erstmals belastet
worden das so das problem derzeit man
muss sich doch nur angucken wie viele
insolvenzen es gibt wie viel
arbeitsplätze das kostet ich höre nur
horrornachrichten gerade auch aus den
neuen ländern und da muss man etwas tun
da kann man sich sagen ach eigentlich
sind wir schon ganz schön toll und die
koalition hält zusammen nein es stimmt
ja völlig richtig wir haben eine
multiple krise und der putins krieg
dieser furchtbare angriffskrieg
russlands hat das alles verschärft aber
werden sagte ist der alleinige grund das
einfach nicht wahr die energiekrise die
inflation war vorher bereits hoch wir
hatten vorher bereits ein
versorgungsproblem die ganze frage klima
die spielt jetzt keine rolle mehr das
geht jetzt weniger an herrn vogel
sondern eher an die grünen dass 1,5 grad
ziel ja das können wir irgendwie in den
wind schreiben also diese vielen krisen
da erwarte ich dass wir in einer
gemeinsamen kraftanstrengung natürlich
die regierung aber bitte auch unter
aufnahme der hinweise der opposition
agieren weil wir haben sonst eine
situation dass wir einen wirklich heißen
herbst bekommen der soziale friede in
unserem land ist gefährdet man muss sich
mit den menschen unterhalten die
wirklich am monatsende schon lange kein
geld mehr haben und da muss gehandelt
werden das ist meine feste überzeugung
wir zumindest werden weiter druck machen
dass ein viertes entlastungspaket wie
immer man das nennt denn diese haushalt
der hier behandelt wird ist letztlich
makulatur es muss alles neu gemacht
werden dass das aber wirklich die
verluste ausgleich das muss dringend was
das ist kann ihn die von herrn barth in
dieser sekunde frau mast hat das heute
morgen auch unterfüttert ist wird neue
pakete geben müssen schätzungsweise denn
allein die arbeitslosigkeit über die hat
noch überhaupt keiner gesprochen den
letzten wochen und monate die wird jetzt
galoppieren zu nehmen alleine da wird
der bundesfinanzminister schon nach
nürnberg ii mehr geld überweisen müssen
sie werden doch daran nicht vorbei
kommen wir wissen doch die doppelte
krise verantwortungsbewusst bewältigen
und das heißt wir haben die krise bei
energie werden die notwendigkeit gezielt
zu entlasten und wir haben die krise bei
inflation das belastet die bürger
mittelfristig auch am schärfsten wenn
sich das rein frisst so und da müssen
wir verantwortung bewusst agieren das
geht wenn wir uns die lage anschauen und
opposition und regierung vielleicht
gemeinsam verantwortungsvoll agieren
dann wäre das gut das geht aber ganz
sicher nicht dadurch dass die opposition
in den klassischen modus verfällt immer
zu sagen höher schneller weiter und vor
allem dinge gegeneinander ausspielt also
100 milliarden entlastungen sind jetzt
dieses jahr auf dem weg und natürlich
mussten die 100 milliarden in die hand
die bundeswehr handlungsfähig zu machen
weil wir einen krieg in europa haben und
wladimir putin nicht in der ukraine
zwingend halt macht wenn man ihnen nicht
einhalt gebietet so also das
gegeneinander ausspielen so in die
klassischen reflexe verfallen das
überzeugt mich nicht zielgenau zu
entlasten und auch breit und mit einem
kräftigen paket zu entlasten ist ja
genau was wir seit wochen im sommer
diskutiert haben was wir jetzt tun und
jetzt muss ich gucken welche elemente
fehlen noch aber das gegeneinander wenn
ich das sagen darf dass wir deshalb
schon nicht funktionieren weil nur für
die nachfolgeregelung dass neun euro
tickets wie immer sie denn aussehen mag
wie sehr offen wenn sie die zustimmung
im bundesrat brauchen das ist nur ein
punkt verloren haben und stein geht
entweder entweder sie kriegen das so hin
dass sie das auch mit den
oppositionsparteien machen die auch
regierungsverantwortung tragen wie in
vier ländern die union viel mehr oder es
wird nichts deswegen kann ich nur raten
hier nicht zu sagen auch die ampel schon
klasse und nur ihr seid die ewigen
nörgler und wollte mehr nein es geht um
qualitative dinge sie haben auch vom
strombereich lieber kollege maximilian
aber dann brauchen sie doch keine
strohmänner haben jetzt das dritte mal
gesagt was ich angeblich gesagt habe was
ich vorher gar nicht gesagt habe lassen
wir doch das ritualisierte und annette
einrichtung welche ausnahme lage die das
land und
ich habe meine damen und herren da
mussten wir hart aussteigen friedrich
merz der oppositionsführer hat jetzt
hier live das wort
das ist mehr als angemessen dass wir
heute morgen dem verstorbenen letzten
staatspräsidenten der ehemaligen
sowjetunion und generalsekretär der kp
de su gedacht haben
wir verdanken
helmut kohl george bush und eben auch
michael gorbatschow die chance dass
unser land vor über 30 jahren die
wiedervereinigung in frieden und
freiheit erreichen könnte
hätte gorbatschow seinen politischen weg
weitergehen können wären
blass most und perestroika die prägenden
elemente der russischen politik
nach dem ende der sowjetunion geblieben
dann wären nicht nur die russische
geschichte anders verlaufen
die gesamte europäische geschichte wäre
anders verlaufen
aber spätestens seit dem russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine sind wir
auf schreckliche weise mit einer ganz
anderen realität konfrontiert und diese
realität hat folgen für ganz europa aber
auch und ganz besonders für deutschland
wir haben seit ihrer regierungserklärung
herr bundeskanzler am 27 februar über
diese folgen oft und intensiv diskutiert
wir haben gemeinsame entscheidungen
getroffen bis hin zu einer änderung des
grundgesetzes mit einer gemeinsamen
entschließung des deutschen bundestages
am 28 april über umfassende humanitäre
finanzielle und militärische hilfe für
die ukraine
mit diesen beiden entscheidungen enden
dann aber auch die gemeinsamkeiten
zwischen ihrer regierung und ob so weit
der bundeshaushalt betroffen ist über
den wir in dieser woche in erster lesung
beraten
halten sie ihre eigene zusagen nicht ein
der bundeskanzler der bundeswehr zieht
ab sie erinnern sich möglicherweise ab
sofort jedes jahr ab sofort jedes jahr
mehr als zwei prozent des bip für
investitionen in die bündnisse und
verteidigungsfähigkeit zur verfügung zu
stellen der bundeswehr etat hätte neben
den
100 milliarden euro die wir zusammen
geschlossen haben jahr für jahr
ansteigen müssen stattdessen kürzen sie
von diesem jahr auf das nächste jahr den
etat um 300 millionen euro
herr bundeskanzler wir müssen leider
feststellen wir können den von ihnen
gegebenen zusagen nicht vertrauen
neben den rein finanziellen fragen der
ausstattung der bundeswehr kommen sie
und ihre regierung auch der eindeutigen
aufforderung des deutschen bundestages
vom 28 april nicht nach die ukraine in
ausreichendem maße mit schweren waffen
zu versorgen und fällt niemandem von uns
leicht zu verstehen dass der einsatz von
waffen den frieden näher bringen kann
aber lassen sie mich vielleicht zitieren
aus einem interview lassen sie mich
zitieren aus einem interview dass einer
der renommiertesten national und
international anerkannten
politikwissenschaftler unseres landes
vor zwei wochen in der berliner zeitung
gegeben hat es ist herfried münkler er
sagt ich bin erstaunt über die naivität
eines teils der intellektuellen szene
und mancher politiker in deutschland
die offenbar glauben dass putin an den
verhandlungstisch kommen wird wenn man
ihn dazu auffordert das gegenteil ist
der fall
russland so sagt er muss durch
militärische misserfolge zu gesprächen
mit der ukraine gezwungen werfen werden
mit waffenlieferungen aus dem ausland
beschleunigt man also einen prozess an
dessen ende verhandlungen stehen
in deutschland
gibt es offenbar keine kultur des
militärisch strategischen denkens
deswegen werden diese aus expertensicht
absurden forderungen nicht als falsch
erkannt der weg so schließt er an den
verhandlungstisch wird einzig über
militärische erfolge der ukraine die
russland die aussicht auf den großen
sieg nehmen ende des zitats der
bundeskanzler
der bundeskanzler
diese klaren worte diese klaren worte
hätten wir einmal von ihnen erwartet
damit hätten sie nicht nur in
deutschland sondern damit hätten sie für
ganz europa ein bisschen politische
führung übernommen
die worte von herfried münkler ernst und
wir tun das dann ist die zögerlichkeit
der
ukraine noch intensiver zu helfen einen
grund dafür dass dieser krieg sich
verlängert er fordert noch mehr opfer
auf beiden seiten als dieser krieg
ohnehin schon gefordert hat die länge
dieses krieges verschärft auch die
wirtschaftliche lage in deutschland und
in europa wir müssen heute meine damen
und herren davon ausgehen dass vor allem
deutschland aufgrund seiner ich sage
ausdrücklich nicht von dieser regierung
allein zu verantwortenden
energieabhängigkeit von russland in
besonderem maße von diesem drohenden
versorgungsengpässen
ich habe es doch gerade gesagt
ausdrücklich nicht von ihnen allein zu
verantworten der abhängigkeit von
russischem gas in besonderer weise
betroffen
doch jenseits aller details
meine damen und herren jenseits aller
details und ich werde auch zwei zu
sprechen kommen fehlt ihnen und ihrer
regierung aber auch in
wirtschaftspolitischer hinsicht jeder
kompass ja man muss es leider sagen auch
in der wirtschaftspolitik fehlt dieser
bundesregierung jede fähigkeit zum
politisch strategischen denken
[Musik]
sie mühen und streiten sich über wochen
und monate die gesamte sommerpause ist
doch bestimmt gewesen von einem
permanenten streit dieser koalition über
wochen und herausgekommen ist wieder
einmal ein sammelsurium an kompromissen
auf dem niveau des kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenners den diese koalition noch
zusammenhält weit davon entfernt weit
davon entfernt
sachgerechte antworten auf diese
gewaltigen herausforderungen zu gehen
vor denen wir stehen und lassen sie mich
meine damen und herren beginnen mit
einer rein formalen frage der frage der
zuständigkeiten spätestens diese krise
und das durcheinander in ihrer koalition
hätten sie herr bundeskanzler zum anlass
nehmen müssen im bundeskanzleramt einen
energie sicherheitsrat noch besser einen
nationalen sicherheitsrat aus
mitgliedern der bundesregierung und
experten von außen einzurichten
spätestens diese krise wäre veranlassen
gewesen die zuständigkeit an sich zu
ziehen wenn sie können die hoch
komplexen fragen der energiepolitik und
der versorgungssicherheit unseres landes
in einer solchen existenziellen krise
doch nicht allen ernstes einen
bundeswirtschaftsminister überlassen der
zwar wie wir immer wieder sehen gefällig
formulieren kann dem wir immer wieder
beim denken zuschauen dürfen der aber
umgeben ist sie aber umgeben ist ganz
offensichtlich in seiner partei und in
seinem apparat von einer gruppe aus
lobbyisten der umweltpolitik die alles
zur strecke bringen was auch nur einige
in aussicht auf erfolg hat diese krise
in dem clip
und mit verlaub wie hilflos er habe sie
in diesen fragen sind das konnte man
gestern abend im deutschen fernsehen
beobachtet man kann nur hoffen man kann
nur hoffen dass
ein großteil der deutschen
mittelständischen unternehmer und vor
allem der bäckerinnen und bäcker um
diese uhrzeit schon im bett gelegen
haben und geschlafen haben und das nicht
mit ansehen mussten was sie da gestern
abend von gegeben hat man kann nur
hoffen
das beste
das große problem vor dem wir heute
stehen meine damen und herren ist die
hohe geldentwertung die jahrelange nur
zinspolitik der ezb hat den sparern in
deutschland erst die renditen
vorenthalten und jetzt geht es an die
substanz und noch weitreichender sind
die folgen noch weitreichender sind die
folgen für unsere gesamte
volkswirtschaft viele unternehmen ja wie
sie diese zwischen wofür meine damen und
herren zeigen nur dass sie ganz
offensichtlich keine ahnung von dem
haben was in den privaten haushalten und
in den unternehmen im augenblick in
deutschland schuss wir haben
offensichtlich keine an ich gebe ihnen
mal ein beispiel
viele unternehmen viele unternehmen in
deutschland haben die auftragsbücher im
augenblick so voll wie schon seit jahren
nicht mehr aber sie können diese
aufträge nicht abarbeiten sie geben sie
zurück weil die lieferketten
unterbrochen sind weil die preise durch
die decke gehen und weil sie nicht mehr
in der lage sind die aufträge
abzuarbeiten diesen schon seit längerer
zeit in den büchern stehen haben das hat
etwas mit der inflationsrate und der
geldentwertung und den lieferketten zu
tun schauen sie sich das doch bitte in
ihren wahlkreisen einmal an jeder von
uns bekommt jeden tag nachrichten und
briefe aus den unternehmen die genau auf
diesen sachverhalt hinweisen und sie
gehen mit einer bemerkenswerten ignoranz
über dieses thema hinweg und reden nur
über hilfsprogramme stadt einmal das
thema wirklich an der wurzel zu packen
in
ihrem papier vom vergangenen sonntag
nach lösungen zu diesem problem stößt
man vor allem
gratulation an die fdp dass sie die
kalte progression abbauen wollen meine
damen und herren das steht im gesetz
dass sie das ohnehin machen müssen und
sie sind dazu verpflichtet diese frage
alle zwei jahre zu klären und es gibt
doch zumindest eine moralische
verpflichtung das jetzt zu tun und nicht
erst im jahr 2023 sondern jetzt im jahr
2022 wäre die richtige antwort im jahr
der krise gewesen diese entscheidung zu
treffen
stattdessen stattdessen halten sie fest
stattdessen halten sie fest an der
gasanlage die zum erster oktober nun in
kraft treten sollen diese gasanlage wird
die inflationsrate in deutschland noch
weiter in die höhe treiben sie wird die
privaten haushalte noch höher belasten
und sie wird vor allen dingen die
unternehmen in deutschland zu einem
zeitpunkt wo sie es nun überhaupt nicht
gebrauchen können mit tausenden
hunderttausenden millionen zusätzlicher
kosten belasten nur weil sie in dieser
bundesregierung krampfhaft an dieser
umlage festhalten die von anfang an eine
fehlkonstruktion gewesen ist und sie
nicht die kraft haben das jetzt hier zu
korrigieren es wäre richtig gewesen
es wäre richtig gewesen
diese umlage aufzunehmen sie können das
übrigens mit uns zusammen in dieser
woche ton der entsprechende antrag der
liegt im deutschen bundestag vor und
statt dessen die relevanten unternehmen
die gasimporte importeure unter einen
staatlichen schutzschirm zu stellen so
wie wir das mit den banken in der
finanzkrise und mit einigen unternehmen
wegen da während der korona krise einmal
gemacht haben dies ist die systematik
die instrumente sind vorhanden sie
weigern sich auf diese instrumente
zurückgreifen weil sie mit dem kopf
durch die wand wollen und eine einmal
geschlossene entscheidung nicht
zurücknehmen wollen das ist die wahrheit
die dieser markt
nun kommt das meisterstück dieser
regierung nämlich die entscheidung vom
montag dieser woche über den
atomausstieg ich meine damen und herren
zunächst einmal vor der klammert damit
das klar ist natürlich muss man den
menschen in einer solchen situation
helfen wenn die energiepreise steigen
wenn die privaten haushalte hoch
belastet sind muss man helfen und sie
haben durchaus in dem papier vom
vergangenen sonntag einige wichtige
beschlüsse gefasst ich nenne ihnen waren
nur zwei an der zahl
sie beschweren sich doch darüber dass
wir zu viel kritisieren jetzt sage ich
mal etwas sage ich ihnen mal etwas wo
sie richtig liegen sie haben gottseidank
gesehen dass sie die rentnerinnen und
rentner und die studierenden in
deutschland übersehen haben bei dem
letzten hilfspaket und korrigieren das
jetzt aber er bundeskanzler jetzt mal
ganz im ernst 300 euro für jeden
haushalt sie und ich bekomme das in
diesen tagen auch überwiesen
brauchen sie das brauchen wir das oder
gibt es vielleicht in diesem land
haushalte mit einem
durchschnittseinkommen von vielleicht
1500 1600 euro im monat netto die er
1000 euro gebraucht hätten statt alle
300 es wäre besser gewesen dass auf
diejenigen konzentrieren die wirklich
brauchen das mit der gießkanne durchs
land zu gehen und jedem haushalt einen
solchen betrag zu überweisen ich will
eine zweite ich will eine zweite
entscheidung nennen die in der
presseberichterstattung wie ich finde
bedauerlicherweise etwas zu sehr in den
hintergrund getreten ist die
entscheidung die tarifvertragsparteien
das angebot zu machen einen einmalbetrag
von 3000 euro zu verabreden der dann
steuer und abgabenfrei ist ist richtig
und ich will von dieser stelle auch den
tarifvertragsparteien sagen nehmen sie
in dieses angebot in anspruch damit sie
jetzt möglichst schnell den privaten
haushalt mit einer solchen einmalzahlung
helfen das ist eine richtige
entscheidung dieser bundesregierung
aber meine damen und herren das sind
doch alles das sind doch alles
reparaturen an einem problem das sie in
der wurzel nicht anfassen wir haben es
mit dieser gaspreisentwicklung mit einem
klassischen
angebotsschock zu tun was macht man wenn
man einen solchen angebots
schockerlebnis dann versucht man doch
zunächst einmal darauf zu reagieren
indem man alle möglichkeiten nutzt das
vorhandene angebot das immer noch zur
verfügung steht auszuschöpfen und zwar
mit ganzer kraft und jede möglichkeit zu
nutzen
das nennt man meine damen und herren das
nennt man marktwirtschaft der ein oder
andere wirklichen begriff von ihm schon
mal gehört haben so reagiert man in
einer marktwirtschaft auf einen
angebotsschock und diese reaktion wäre
richtig gewesen im hinblick auf die
gesamte palette der energieversorgung
die wir in diesem lande haben
stattdessen wird in dieser regierung
weiter verzögert herum laviert
verhindert und wertvolle zeit vergeudet
ich nenne ihnen ein beispiel beispiele
da sind die steinkohlekraftwerke dem sie
erst die betriebserlaubnis geben wieder
hochzufahren wenn für mehrere wochen die
reserven auf dem hof liegen das gilt für
die biomasse wir haben hier darüber
gesprochen sie wollten den deckel
aufheben der ist bis heute bei 1000 mw
gedeckelt es nach wie vor vorhanden aus
biomasse könnte das zehnfache an strom
gewonnen werden was wir heute unter
diesem deckel liegen haben das gibt mir
die
das geht für die braunkohlekraftwerke
von denen immer noch einige blöcke
stillstehen und das ergebnis ist dass
wir im jahr 2022 mehr gas verströmt
haben als in vielen jahren vorher wir
sind in einem land in die in einer zeit
in der gas gespart werden muss
gespeichert werden muss und durch ihre
blockadehaltung gegenüber anderen formen
der stromerzeugung fahren wir in
deutschland die gaskraftwerke hoch und
erzeugen strom obwohl es andere
möglichkeiten gebe diesen strom zu
erzeugen und dann und dann diese
entscheiden dann
diese entscheidung meine damen und
herren zur kernenergie was sie da am
montag verkündet haben er habe ich jetzt
hat das parlament schon verlassen
wahrscheinlich guckt dass ich gerade mal
die filme von gestern abend an
aber meine damen und herren los da am
montagabend was da am montagabend
verkündet worden ist das gerücht
möglicherweise die grüne basis vor allem
in niedersachsen in wahrheit halten sie
mit dieser politik das ganze land zum
lachen und beschädigen möglicherweise
unwiderruflich die deutschen unternehmen
den gesamten wirtschaftsstandort und vor
allem die mittelständischen unternehmen
in unserem land
damit
bei damen und herren damit dass
von dieser stelle aus klar wird weil die
das hin und wieder auch anders in
deutschland verbreiten niemand von uns
will zurück zur alten kernenergie
[Applaus]
also vielleicht muss ich so für sie
vielleicht muss ich für sie noch mal
wiederholen damit sie es verstehen
niemand von uns weg zurück zur alten
kernenergie die wir 2011 in deutschland
beendet haben aber in einer es nicht
die ganze die ganze ignoranz zu diesem
thema die steht ihnen ins gesicht
geschrieben wenn man von dieser stelle
aus wenn man von dieser aktie aus strick
wir haben wir haben in deutschland
wir haben in deutschland noch drei
laufenden kernkraftwerke das sind die
modernsten und sichersten
kernkraftwerke der welt die ganze welt
drum herum schaut auf deutschland und
draußen sagen die leute sind diese
deutschen eigentlich verrückt geworden
in einer solchen situation drei
kernkraftwerke stillzulegen
die in der lage wäre rund zehn millionen
haushalte sicher mit strom zu versorgen
das ist das hat auch ein niveau an die
nationalität erreicht das kann man doch
gar nicht mehr beschreiben wir haben
ihnen das angebot gemacht in den
sommerferien eine sondersitzung des
deutschen bundestages durchzuführen mit
einer änderung des atomgesetzes
wir hätten mit ihnen gemeinsam den weg
gegangen dies für 304 jahre zu
ermöglichen nicht mehr aber bitte auch
nicht weniger aber das was sie jetzt da
machen ist doch ein fauler kompromiss
die beiden atomkraftwerke die nach ihrem
willen im standby betrieb bleiben sollen
und alle fachleute sagen ihnen dass das
hochgradiger unfug ist das zu machen
müssen die komplette mannschaft
vorhalten bleiben am netz sollen
hochgefahren werden wenn wir ein problem
in deutschland habe ich sage ihnen wir
werden nicht nur ein problem haben habe
ich sie haben vor einigen wochen mal
gesagt wir hätten keinen strom problem
wir hätten ein gas problem wir sind
in einem massiven stromproblem in diesem
land und sie haben es offensichtlich bis
heute nicht verstanden dass es so ist so
wenn sie wenn sie dafür sorgen wollen
dass die preise runtergehen in
deutschland dass die hilfsmaßnahmen die
wir gemeinsam vielleicht ergreifen
müssen nicht überborden und den haushalt
überstrapazieren dann muss man aus der
angebotsseite alles tun damit genug
strom damit genug energie in diesem
lande verfügbar ist und das ist keine
frage der netzstabilität die hat sie
haben prüfen lassen das ist eine frage
der stromerzeugung kapazitäten in
deutschland regen sie sich mal nicht auf
die parlaments- ärztin ist da wenn sie
wollen können sie gleich sehen
also hinein ist für ihn sagen oder eines
zu ihnen sagen wenn sie wenn sie mit
ihrer fraktion der meinung sind diese
probleme die wir jetzt haben zum
gegenstand von auseinandersetzungen auf
den straßen in deutschland machen zu
wollen dann werden wir ihnen mit allem
was wir haben und notfalls mit allen
anderen zusammen im parlament entgegen
treten wir werden es nicht zulassen dass
sie die
mit ihrer politik die stabilisieren das
werden wir nicht
und was machen wir dann nochmals allen
anderen kicker und dann darf sie da ihr
traum ist ungebrochen
nein meine damen und herren herr
bundeskanzler
ich will es ihnen auch wirklich sagen
für auf zeit muss diese kapazitäten am
netz bleiben damit senken wir die preise
damit senken wir die kosten für die
unternehmen damit schaffen wir
planungssicherheit auch für die
unternehmen in deutschland und ich will
sie aufrufen die lage spitzt sich in den
nächsten tagen wochen und monaten
möglicherweise dramatisch zu und sie
wissen es sie haben die gesprächspartner
die ihnen das gesagt haben das dürfte
alles andere als eine übertreibung sein
ich sage ihnen herr bundeskanzler
stoppen sie diesen irrsinn aus ihrer
koalition so lange wir die zeit dafür
noch haben herzlichen dank
ein angriffslustiger oppositionsführer
friedrich merz der nicht etwa mit den
atomkraftwerken angefangen hat sondern
mit ihnen wendet hat der schlusssatz
stoppen sie diesen irrsinn bundeskanzler
so lange wir noch die zeit haben er hat
vorne noch einmal gorbatschow gewürdigt
und hat unter anderem die geldpolitik
angegriffen der ezb die nullzinspolitik
die geldentwertung ist eine logische
folge des lösung dieses problems habe
sich die bundesregierung zum beispiel
bisher noch überhaupt nichts zugewandt
er hat unter anderem die
gaspreisentwicklung noch einmal
verdeutlicht dass es ein klassisches
angebot seien klassische angebotsschock
sei der hier vorliegt und dass das
angebot nicht verknappt sondern dass so
viel wie möglich energie erzeugt werden
muss weshalb die union ja der meinung
ist dass die drei akw es die nächsten
zwei winter noch weiter zu laufen haben
und die antwort jetzt von bundeskanzler
olaf scholz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
verehrten kolleginnen kollegen
fährt der kollege merz ich habe ihnen
eben sehr genau zugehört
ich will ihnen ich will ihn einst
antworten
unterschätzen sie unser land nicht
unterschätzen sie nicht die bürgerinnen
und bürger dieses landes
in schweren zeiten wächst unser land
über sich selbst hinaus wir haben eine
gute tradition uns unter zu hacken wenn
es schwierig wird bund länder und
kommunen politik zivilgesellschaft
arbeitgeber und betriebsräte unternehmen
und gewerkschaften der spaltung
herbeiredet der gefährde den
zusammenhalt in diesem land und das ist
jetzt das falsche
und außerdem ist es so dass wir in einer
situation sind in der die union die
meisten probleme schon als gelöst
vorgefunden hat bevor sie sie überhaupt
erörtert hat ich will das mal ganz klar
sagen bereits im dezember habe ich die
zuständigen minister gefragt was ist
eigentlich wenn wir schwierigkeiten
kriegen mit lieferungen aus russland und
wir haben uns bis zum kriegsausbruch
darauf sorgfältig vorbereitet um dann in
dieser situation entscheidung zu treffen
die weitreichend sind und die
weitreichend auch jetzt schon umgesetzt
worden sind etwas auf dass niemand
anders sich vorbereitet hat
wir haben zum beispiel entschieden um
mit dieser bedrohung klarzukommen dass
wir den norddeutschen küsten
flüssiggasterminals bauen dass wir die
pipelines bauen die dazu notwendig sind
damit ihr unabhängig von russland gast
nach deutschland importieren können wir
haben die kapazitäten aus den
niederlanden aus belgien jetzt aus
frankreich erweitert weil wir ein
problem bedacht und uns vorbereitet
haben über das sie damals noch nicht
einmal gesprochen haben
und in einem tempo zudem keine cdu
geführte regierung in diesem land je
fähig gewesen ist werden wir es schaffen
im januar werden die ersten dieser
terminals ihren betrieb aufnehmen das
ist eine gemeinschaftsleistung in
deutschland
und werden cdu geführt der minister es
überhaupt kein problem fahren
ministerien ist überhaupt kein problem
fanden dass die speicher für gas in
diesem land leer waren im letzten jahr
haben wir dafür gesorgt dass sich das
ändert mit gesetzen und regelungen die
wir auf den weg gebracht haben
sie hatten noch nicht mehr in der
opposition ist er fertig gebracht das
eigene versäumnisse als problemen der
neuen regierung unterzuschieben wir
hatten es schon gelöst bevor sie
überhaupt mitbekommen haben dass er
einst war das ist die wahrheit gerechnet
und während wir mit den speichern zu
gast in deutschland so unverantwortlich
vorgegangen wie das die zu vorher
verantwortlichen der vorher
verantwortliche minister und die
regierung gehabt haben dann würde ich
ihnen ausdrücklich sagen hätten wir
jetzt nicht 85% speicherkapazität
sondern quasi nichts so wie im letzten
jahr das ist der unterschied zwischen
der union und den verteidiger das land
sie hier
sie haben noch hilfe gefordert dass wir
dafür sorgen sollen dass die speicher
voll sind und da haben wir die gesetze
schon gemacht sie könnten auch mal sagen
dass sie das eine beeindruckende
leistung finden herren hatte
und da gibt es noch ein thema auf das
sie gar nicht gekommen sind über das sie
nie geredet haben wo sie nichts
gefordert haben als es darauf angekommen
wäre wir haben gesetze auf den weg
gebracht die dafür sorgen dass
kohlekraftwerke in diesem land in dem
betrieb gehen können klasse genutzt
werden können dass sie nicht
abgeschaltet werden alles das haben wir
auf den weg gebracht das war eine
notwendige leistung mit großer
geschwindigkeit und großem tempo die wir
hier auf den weg gebracht haben
und sogar solche fragen wie diese ihren
nebenbei angesprochen sind längst dabei
gelöst zu werden wie zum beispiel das
natürlich die kohlekraftwerke loslegen
können auch wenn sie nicht genügend
gelagert haben und auch die tatsache ist
die biomasse anlagen dass die
solaranlagen alle aus alles an kraft
zeigen können was sie brauchen das haben
wir gesetzlich alles vorbereitet sie
brauchen nur noch zugucken wie das
geschieht es ist schon erledigt bevor
sie es ausgesprochen haben
und wir haben ein gesetz gemacht fuel
switch die gesetzlichen regelungen dafür
geschaffen dass überall in deutschland
betriebe und unternehmen entscheidungen
treffen können dass sie nicht auf gast
zurückgreifen müssen sondern andere
anlagen betreiben können damit wir
gemeinsam gas sparen und durch diesen
winter kommt auch das haben diese schon
gemacht sie haben es noch nicht mal
gefordert
ja und ich weiß ist schon sehr
enttäuschend weil sie sich so sehr auf
das thema der kernenergie konzentriert
haben aber das was wir jetzt vorbereiten
ist dass die möglichkeit besteht dass
wir die kernkraft anlagen die
atomanlagen im süden deutschlands
betreiben können damit es niemals ein
strom lange in deutschland gibt auch
wenn das in diesem winter im januar
februar und märz notwendig ist das ist
vorbereitet und das ist die grundlage
dafür dass das ganze was sie sich schon
vor zwei wochen als rhetorisches konzept
erlegt import überlegt haben hier heute
gescheitert ist
sie reden einfach am thema und an den
problemen dieses landes vorbei und das
ist wirklich ein ganz ganz großes
problem und wenn andere die probleme
lösen die sie noch nicht mal erkannt
haben dann reden sie auch noch drum rum
im übrigen ist das jetzt eine situation
in der wir anders als vor einem jahr
weil wir soviel eingespeichert haben
weil wir all diese vorkehrungen
getroffen haben weil wir all diese
entscheidung getroffen haben in einer
situation sind in der wir sank um können
wir kommen wohl durch trotz aller
anspannung durch diesen winter mit den
vorbereitungen die wir gemacht haben das
hätte niemand vor drei monaten vor vier
monaten vor fünf monaten vor am beginn
des jahres sagen könnt und weil wir so
früh angefangen haben als noch gar nicht
ein so großes problem problembewusstsein
in deutschland da war darum sind wir
jetzt in der lage dass wir tapfer und
mutig in diesem winter hinein gehen
können dass unser land das überstehen
wird das ist die sache die wir gemacht
haben
insofern sind sie also schief gewickelt
wenn ich das mal so sagen nach sie haben
einfach an dem thema vorbei geredet dass
unser land wirklich umtreibt und wir
sind jetzt dabei die nächsten dinge zu
tun die notwendig sind damit die bürgern
und bürger und unsere wirtschaft durch
diese situation kommen wir haben bereits
zwei entlastungspaket verschlossen und
jetzt kommt das dritte weil wir ganz
konkret gucken was zu tun ist wie wir es
schaffen können dass die bürgel und
bürger dass die unternehmen dieses
landes dass der mittelstand die großen
unternehmen die möglichkeiten haben die
sie brauchen damit sie weiter
produzieren können damit die
arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben damit man
sich das leben leisten kann und ich
finde es ist richtig dass wir das getan
haben wir haben zwei erste pakete von
knapp 30 milliarden euro bereits
beschlossen jetzt kommt 1 noch einmal
dazu dass knapp 65 milliarden euro
umfasst alles zusammen eine ziemlich
große summe und es dient dazu dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger durch diese zeit
kommen dass die unternehmen kommen durch
die zeit kommen und dass die
arbeitsplätze gesichert werden you never
walk alone das ist das motto dieser
regierung
ich bin sicher unser land wird über sich
heraus wachsen wir werden zusammenhalten
wir werden die herausforderung bestehen
vor dem wir uns jetzt befinden und wir
werden die probleme lösen die wir
miteinander haben weil wir niemanden
alleine lassen mit seinen
herausforderungen und dazu dienen auch
all die entscheidung die wir getroffen
haben zum beispiel die entscheidung zu
sagen dass jetzt wo in diesem monat die
energiepreis prämie gezahlt wird das
anders als möglichkeit bei den
arbeitnehmern arbeitnehmern ankommt
haben der auch entschieden dass es auch
für rentnerinnen und rentner und
studenten gelten soll das ist eine
entlastung in einer schwierigen zeit wo
alles teurer wird richtig dass wir das
tun
wir machen eine bürgergeld reformen die
dafür sorgt dass diejenigen die sehr
wenig geld haben auch durch diese zeit
kommen können dass sie unterstützt
werden aber vor allem sorgen wir dafür
dass teil diejenigen die diesem land
arbeiten oder als renten um rentner
einmal gearbeitet haben all die
unterstützung bekommen die sie brauchen
damit sie das finanzieren können was an
teuren lebenshaltungskosten bei ihnen
ankommt und das ist geschehen mit den
dingen die ich schon genannt habe aber
zb auch mit der größten wohngeldreform
seit der einführung des wohngelds in
diesem land zwei millionen berechtigte
stadt 700.000 das wird unglaublich viele
familien in diesem land besser stellen
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern mit
geringen einkommen und rentnern rentner
eine richtige eine notwendige
entscheidung
zb indem wir dafür sorgen dass familien
unterstützt werden das kindergeld wird
erhöht die schritte die für das nächste
und das übernächste jahr anfallen machen
ziehen wir zusammen machen das in ein
schritt mit 18 euro wir sorgen dafür
dass der kinderzuschlag verbessert wird
da geht es für manche familien um ein
paar hundert euro im jahr die sie mehr
zur verfügung haben eine richtige eine
notwendige entscheidung in dieser zeit
wir sorgen dafür dass diejenigen die
wenig verdienen und dem wir mit
steuerentlastungen wenig helfen können
eine entlastung bekommen indem wir die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge für die sie
zahlen müssen absenken und dafür sorgen
dass bis zum einem einkommen von 2000
euro die progressionszone bei den
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen fortgesetzt
wird das sind über 1,3 milliarden euro
netto entlastung für diejenigen die am
wenigsten in diesem land verdienen und
von steuersenkung sonst nichts hätten
nicht zu vergessen dass gerade jetzt
wenn das stattfindet zum ersten oktober
der mindestlohn noch zwölf euro
angehoben wird in einer solchen zeit
eine dringend notwendige entscheidung
für die wir uns lange eingesetzt haben
meine damen und herren
und wir entlasten die bürgerinnen und
bürger in dem der steuersenkung
beschließen in großem umfang in dem wir
auf die inflation reagieren und
dementsprechend das flächendeckend
organisieren mit der anhebung des
freibetrages mit den steuer senken damit
verbunden sind übrigens verknüpft mit
lauter maßnahmen die wir jetzt auf den
weg bringen oder schon auf den weg
gebracht haben wie zb dass die
rentenbeiträge abgezogen werden können
vom steuereinkommen voller höhe das sind
die beiden nächsten jahre zusammen fünf
milliarden euro entlastung für
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmer eine
richtige entscheidung und eine
notwendige entscheidung
und wir haben dafür gesorgt dass die
arbeitnehmerpauschale angehoben wird das
wird weiter im nächsten jahr gelten dass
die pendlerpauschale angehoben ist auch
das sind dinge die alle da zusammen
beitragen dass wir eine möglichkeit
haben durch diese zeit zu kommen und für
uns ist auch wichtig dass wir uns nicht
nur auf uns alleine beschränken ich habe
schon vor der sommerpause gesprochen in
der konzertierten aktion mit
unternehmensvertretern mit
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber mit den
gewerkschaften mit der wissenschaft der
bundesbank über die frage was wir machen
können wenn wir uns unterhalten und
deshalb ist die konzertierte aktion eine
notwendige antwort des zusammenhalts auf
diese krise und wir werden deren
entscheidungen und die aktivitäten der
unternehmen unterstützen indem wir sagen
wenn jetzt wegen dieser preis streuung
der höheren energiekosten die
sozialpartner die gewerkschaften und die
arbeitgeber vereinbaren das ist höhere
sonderzahlungen gibt dann werden wir bis
zu 3000 euro steuer- und abgabenfrei
ermöglichen das ist eine konkrete
botschaft des zusammenhalts in
deutschland und eine botschaft der tat
partnerschaft
sie sehen also wir haben sehr viel
gemacht um die drängenden probleme
vieler bürgerinnen und bürger in den
griff zu bekommen und wir werden das
auch weiter tun weil das notwendig ist
die maßnahmen die wir gemacht haben
haben wir auch große erfahrung mit sich
gebracht viele haben hier sehr skeptisch
diskutiert ich erinnere mich an einige
äußerungen aus der union wenn ich das
richtig dass wir das neun euro ticket
einführen und ich sage ausdrücklich das
war eine große sache die skeptiker
hatten nicht recht und deshalb wird es
eine fortsetzung geben für eine lösung
die das möglich macht bundesweit
abonnierbare digital buchbare tickets zu
haben die zu einem vertretbaren tarif
überall in deutschland die nutzung des
nahverkehrs möglich machen eine gute
entscheidung aus der krise gewachsen
aber für viel viel längere zeit sinnvoll
was dann natürlich dazu kommt ist dass
wir die herausforderung bewältigen
müssen die mit den steigenden
energiekosten verbunden sind wir haben
also als sie noch nicht daran gedacht
hatten schon das problem gelöst wie
sichern wir die energieversorgung
deutschlands
was nicht möglich gewesen ist denn die
cdu/csu ist die partei die die komplette
verantwortung dafür hat dass deutschland
ausstiegs entscheidung getroffen hat aus
der kohle und aus der atomenergie aber
die niemals die kraft hatte in
irgendetwas einzusteigen sie waren
unfähig dem ausbau der erneuerbaren
energie herbeizuführen
sie haben ab der kämpfe geführt gegen
jede einzelne windkraftanlage und jeder
ab der kampf der letzten jahre schadet
unserem land noch heute das von sie
dafür haben sie auch immer sehr reizt
eckige mogelt die letzte mogelei war vor
der letzten bundestagswahl unions
geführtes wirtschaftsministerium mit
absicht wurde die wahrheit dass wir bis
zum ende dieses jahrzehnts ein anstieg
des stromproduktion von 600 terawatt auf
800 terawatt brauchen verschwiegen und
als der bundestag in die sommerpause kam
da wurde es veröffentlicht das ist
unverantwortliche cdu politik die uns
die jetzige situation gewachsen
naja herbergs
hören sie genau zu
als ich vorgeschlagen hat in der
bundesregierung wir sollten doch
flüssiggasterminals bauen an den
norddeutschen kürzen wir sollten doch
flüssiggas terminals an den deutschen
küsten baum und wir dazu einen brief
entwickelt hatten hat ein mitglied der
bundesregierung vermutlich cdu dass dem
spiegel gesteckt damit sich alle darüber
aufregen dass wir das tun hätten wir es
man getan will ich ausdrücklich dazu
sagen dann müssen wir jetzt nicht mit
diesem tempo das macht
und eine partei die bis heute fast jede
windkraftanlage persönlich bekämpft hat
überhaupt nichts zu tun mit der frage
wie lösen geriet die energieversorgungs
probleme der zukunft das ist die
wahrheit wir aber haben in diesem jahr
schon mehrere gesetze auf den weg
gebracht und werden noch weitere auf den
weg fragen die dazu führen dass wir in
dem notwendigen schnellen tempo den
ausbau von erneuerbaren energien
zustande kriegen offshore wind onshore
in solaranlagen ein starkes
leistungsfähiges netz und
selbstverständlich alles was dazu gehört
und wer auch schon ein paar probleme
weniger wenn es nicht der heroische
kampf der csu in bayern gewesen wäre
dafür zu sorgen dass noch nicht alle
übertragungsnetz leitungen in den süden
deutschlands errichtet worden sind das
war das was sie gemacht haben
für tragen sie die verantwortung
es war unverantwortlich das zu tun und
es ist gut dass sie in der opposition
sind damit wir die industrielle
modernisierung unseres landes hinkriegen
damit wir wettbewerbsfähig bleiben und
uns nicht mehr vor dem problem dieses
landes brücken
ja wir müssen unabhängig werden von den
gasimporten aus russland und das werden
wir in großer geschwindigkeit tun in
wilhelmshaven in stade in wulsbüttel in
lubmin werden neue terminals entstehen
wir haben an den westeuropäischen kosten
mit unseren freunden gesprochen in den
niederlanden in belgien dass sie die
terminals ausbauen und die
leitungskapazität mit frankreich das das
erste mal gast zu uns liefern wird wir
haben probleme gelöst da hatten sie noch
gar nicht mitgekriegt dass die überhaupt
existieren und das ist das was wir jetzt
zustande gebracht haben wird den
terminals am morgen und mit denen man
den deutschen mäster europäischen küsten
werden wir eine sichere
energieversorgung für deutschland
gewährleisten
fast aber natürlich auch dazu gehört und
das will ich dazu sagen ist dass wir
jetzt mit denen nachdem wir die
versorgungssicherheit zum großen thema
gemacht haben auch das problem mit den
preisen in den griff nehmen und deshalb
ist es richtig dass wir sagen wir werden
das mag design auf dem strommarkt
verändern wir werden nicht zulassen dass
die hohen preise die für strom aus
gaskraftwerken heute gezahlten dazu
führen dass es extra große profite geht
für jemanden der das mit windkraft mit
wasserkraft mit solarenergie der das
macht mit braunkohle und steinkohle oder
nuklearenergie sondern wir werden diese
zusätzlichen gewinne abschöpfen um die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu entlasten mit
einer strompreis bremse das ist die
richtige antwort und wir haben sie
gegeben
und natürlich werden wir uns mit einer
frage der gast preise auseinander setzen
müssen und der hohen kohlepreise und
ölpreise die ja alle davon auch mit
berührt sind wir haben uns darum
gekümmert dass das möglich ist wir
sorgen jetzt dafür dass wir zusammen mit
europa diskutieren wie kriegen wir das
thema im griff denn anders als beim
strommarkt geht es ja darum dass sie ihr
importieren aus ländern die die preise
anderswo bestimmt aber wir müssen
trotzdem hinkriegen dass sich das ändert
das erste was wir hinkriegen müssen ist
das wenn wir das geschafft haben worum
wir uns jetzt im eiltempo kümmern und
sich vorher niemand gekümmert hat
nämlich dass wir jederzeit das aus aller
welt importieren können mit den ganzen
terminals über die ich eben gesprochen
hat dass wir den weltmarktpreis nur
bezahlen müssen und nicht die höheren
preise die durch diese fehlenden import
strukturen heute aufgerufen werden aber
wenn wir das geschafft haben dann geht
es jetzt auch darum dass wir den weg
beschreiten wie wir diese preise nach
unten kriegen das werden wir mit unseren
freunden in europa und mit allen hier in
deutschland erörtern denn das ist eine
sache die wir nicht auf sich beruhen
lassen die preise für die
energielieferung müssen runter die
bürgern und bürger müssen die preise
auch bezahlen können und wir werden
dafür sorgen
wir erleben eine zeitenwende ich habe
das hier im deutschen bundestag gesagt
das ist der russische angriffskrieg auf
die ukraine der die europäische
friedens- und sicherheitsrat nung
zertrümmert hat der unverändert eine
riesige große bedrohung ist für frieden
und sicherheit in europa denn das war ja
die verständigung der letzten jahrzehnte
dass das nicht passiert dass man mit
gewalt grenzen verschiebt und etwas
anderes ist es nicht als imperialismus
was der russische präsident versucht
sich nicht mich einfach teile des
nachbar territoriums oder das ganze
anzueignen und man darf ihn auch nicht
missverstehen er hat das ja alles
öffentlich gesagt in aufsätzen
geschrieben es gibt überhaupt nichts an
der frage zu deutschland was seine
absicht ist deshalb unterstützen wir die
ukraine mit unseren verbündeten wir tun
es schon sehr lange und wir tun es sehr
effektiv auch mit den notwendigen
schweren waffen mit artillerie mit
möglichkeiten zur luftverteidigung und
all dem was wir auf den weg gebracht
haben das sind die modernsten waffen die
exakt jetzt in dem gefecht im osten der
ukraine gebraucht werden wir werden das
auch weiter tun das ist unsere
verpflichtung so lange wie es notwendig
ist
und es ist sehr umfangreich was wir
getan haben aber eins unterscheidet uns
von ihnen ganz offensichtlich sie haben
es heute bekannt wir werden keine
alleingänge machen wir werden keine
deutschen alleingänge machen das wäre
ein schwerer schwerer
unverantwortlicher fehler und ich sage
ausdrücklich an die union gerichtet wer
für alleingänge plädiert sollte dieses
land nicht regieren
und was wir tun was wir tun ist
eingebettet in die gemeinsamen handlung
mit unseren verbündeten insbesondere den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und wer
nicht verstehen will wer genau begreifen
will was die regierung leitet der
braucht nur den aufsatz von präsident
biden in der new york times durchlesen
oder exakt das erzählt hat was ich ihnen
hier auch sagen erstens wir werden als
verbündete handeln wir werden keine
entscheidungen treffen die dazu führen
dass der krieg in russland
verbrecherischer weise gegen die ukraine
führt zu einer eskalation eines krieges
führt zwischen nato und russland aber
wir werden das notwendige tun und genau
entlang dieser linie denkt eingebettet
in das bündnis in mit unseren freunden
in aller welt unterstützen wir die
ukraine und werden es so lange machen
wie es notwendig ist
das sind ernste zeiten es sind ernste
zeiten in denen der zusammenhalt in der
gesellschaft von allergrößter bedeutung
ist und deshalb sind es auch zeiten in
denen sich immer wieder beweisen muss zu
was wir miteinander fähig sind ich bin
überzeugt wir sind ein land das diesen
zusammenhalt auch hat das in der lage
ist die schwierige zeit zu bewältigen in
der wir uns jetzt befinden und es auch
in der lage ist den weg in die zukunft
zu beschreiten das haben wir gemacht mit
weitreichenden entscheidungen in diesem
jahr weit reichende entscheidungen als
sie in den letzten jahrzehnten über alle
zeit hinweg verteilt worden sind in
einem einzigen jahr das ist die aufgabe
der regierung und das werden wir auch
weiter zu tun schön dann
ein angriffslustiger bundeskanzler nach
all den jahren unter angela merkel muss
man sich an diesen neuen rede stil erst
einmal gewöhnen er nahm auch eine
eine merkwürdige rede stil ein in dem 70
prozent seiner rede an die union hielt
schon sein erster satz herz
unterschätzen sind unser land nicht wer
spaltung herbeiredet gefährdet den
frieden in unserem land und so ging das
die ganze zeit weiter er hatte der union
vorgehalten was sie alles versäumt hat
und was seine regierung bereits alles
gemacht hat der kanzler wütete gegen die
union sie brauchen nur noch zuschauen
wie all das nun aber geschieht es ist
schon erledigt bevor sie es überhaupt
ausgesprochen haben in seinem redefluss
hat er dann auch noch mal die
entscheidung unterstützt die beiden
atomkraftwerke vorläufig in bereitschaft
zu halten und gegen ende seiner rede
hatte er noch mal verteidigt dass die
bundesregierung durch sehr viele waffen
an die ukraine liefert die nächste
rednerin jetzt hier in der debatte alice
weil die fdp fraktions und parteichef
finden
ist die nabelschau zwischen herrn merz
und dem bundeskanzler vorbei sie haben
damit eindeutig gezeigt dass ihnen die
ernsthaftigkeit fehlt für die lage in
der sich unser land befindet
deutschland steuert in den schwersten
sturm seit bestehen der bundesrepublik
millionen existenzen stehen auf dem
spiel
zahllosen bürgern droht die verarmung
der mittelständischen wirtschaft der
zusammenbruch den staatsfinanzen
dauerhafte zerrüttung und auf der brücke
des schiffs steht der kapitän der
titanic will von eisbergen nichts wissen
und beschwichtigt die leute mit hohlen
durchsagen das haben wir ja gerade
gehört mit so einer besatzung kann die
reise nur im desaster enden ein
bundeskanzler der in ein steuer und
finanzskandal verwickelt ist und sicher
nichts erinnern kann ein
wirtschaftsminister der die bürger
schröpft um lobbyisten und
energiekonzern zu geben aber von
ökonomischen und technologischen
zusammenhängen überhaupt keine ahnung
hat und nicht mehr weiß was insolvenzen
sind wir als gäste haben in einer
talkshow ja von sich gegeben hat ein
finanzminister der schulden systematisch
verschleiert eine innenministerin die
auf dem linken auge blind ist beim
islamismus wegschaut und den
verfassungsschutz als etablierten schutz
missbraucht ein justizminister der
willkürlich grundrechte einschränkt ein
von einem virus besessener
gesundheitsminister der laufen wäre es
und unsinniges von sich gibt eine
verteidigungsministerin die
militärischem gerät offenbar nur dann
etwas anfangen kann wenn es um urlaubs
vehikel taucht und schließlich eine
grüne außenministerin die verspricht an
der seite der ukraine zu stehen
gleichgültig wie hart und verheerend die
sanktionspolitik für die eigenen bürger
wird egal was meine deutschen wähler
denken das ist offenbar das motto dieser
bundesregierung
ihre amtszeit schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden
jetzt zum meineid
ideologische fantasien und arrogantes
festhalten an fehlentscheidungen sind
ihnen wichtiger die verbohrte festhalten
abschalten der letzten kernkraftwerke
ist dafür der beste beleg sie ruinieren
dieses land wirtschaftlich um die
irrationalen dogmen der grünen klientel
und lobbyisten zu bedienen sie haben
allen grund einen heißen herbst und
winter zu fürchten denn die bürger haben
jedes recht herr merz gegen eine solche
regierung und gegen eine solche politik
auf die straße zu gehen natürlich haben
sie das recht galoppierende inflation
eine sterbende währung und
explodierender energiepreise bedeuten
für millionen bürger mehr als nur ein
bisschen frieren wie im gönnerhaft von
oben mitgeteilt wird auch für haushalte
der mittelschicht geht das an die
existenz sie können ihre rechnungen
nicht mehr bezahlen ihre rücklagen
renten und versorgungsansprüche werden
rasant entwertet ihnen droht verarmung
und abhängigkeit
von öffentlicher fürsorge die aber
endlich ist wie wir heute bereits sehen
in der schöpfung der steuerzahler bis in
die existenzvernichtung
viele die heute noch ihre familien
ernähren können werden ihre arbeit
verlieren reihenweise stellen
mittelständische unternehmen bereits
jetzt die produktion ein weil sie die
energierechnung nicht mehr stemmen
können becker und dünger fabriken
porzellan und glas hersteller gießereien
und aluminiumwerke
inflation und energiekrise zerstören den
unternehmerischen mittelstand und die
bürgerliche mittelschicht die
entlastungs paket hat für unseren
mittelstand und für unsere mittelschicht
nichts übrig sie versprechen zuschüsse
die die arbeitende bevölkerung selbst
bezahlen muss
sie verteilen geld das sie den bürgern
vorher mehrfach weggenommen haben und
stellen das als wohltat da
60 prozent der deutschen haushalte
müssen ihre gesamten einkünfte nach
steuern
für die lebenshaltung einsätzen zum
sparen bleibt nichts mehr essen
sparkassen studie sie müssen nicht mit
dem kopf schütteln hier bei den grünen
sondern sie müssen einfach die studien
lesen dass sie das sich wohl noch keine
ahnung davon haben das beweisen sie mit
ihrer politik wenn das das grüne
wirtschaftswunder ist
das im wahlkampf angekündigt wurde dann
danke für nichts und ihre scheinheiligen
appelle und durchhalteparolen an die
bürger sich einzuschränken ob hut zu
bringen und kalt zu duschen waschlappen
zu benutzen für die ukraine für die
energiewende oder für ein klima das
können sie sich sparen das wollen die
leute nicht hören um in dieser krise zu
bestehen muss unser laden die ursachen
von informationen energiekrise angehen
davon habe ich von ihnen nichts gehört
in dieser aussprache inflation und
energiepreise ziehen schon seit mehr als
einem jahr an bei der entwicklung sind
das direkte resultat einer schlechten
jahrzehntelangen politik die energie
krise ist hausgemacht sie ist direkte
folge der energiewende die mit ihrem
schal bahn und u renten steuern und
abgaben stroh künstlich verknappt und
verteuert hat nun sind eine einseitige
abhängigkeit von russischem erdgas gibt
dort hat das ist doch die wahrheit die
grünen wollen doch nicht so tun es ist
ihr angestrebtes ziel die energiekosten
in die höhe zu treiben und damit die
nachfrage einzuschränken da viel haben
sie jetzt ja damit erreicht die
inflation ist zudem das resultat der
maßlosen geldschöpfung null zinspolitik
der ezb zur finanzierung hoch
verschuldeter und aufgeblähter
staatshaushalte zweieinhalb jahre
lockdown politik und eine kopflose
sanktionspolitik als reaktion auf den
ukraine krieg haben das kartenhaus zum
einsturz gebracht die konsequenzen
liegen auf der hand
nur ihre regierung wie sie nicht sehen
und die entsprechenden maßnahmen nicht
ergreifen erstens die steuern müssen
runter senkung der energiesteuern der
mehrwert und der einkommensteuer
streichung der co2 abgabe und eine echte
streichung und abschaffung des
unsäglichen eeg
zweitens die ezb muss in die pflicht
genommen werden ihren auftrag zu
erfüllen und für stabiles geld zu sorgen
drittens die staatsausgaben müssen auf
das wesentliche konzentriert werden
innere und äußere sicherheit
gewährleistung von rechtsstaatlichkeit
und öffentliche ordnung schluss mit
ideologie politik klientel versorgung
und geld verteilen in alle welt
irgendwie legale migration und
einwanderung in die sozialsysteme liegen
schon wieder über dem niveau von 2005 10
aber sie eröffnen die letzten schleusen
und senden neue migration signale durch
fast schon bedingungslose einbürgerung 5
das energieangebot muss ausgeweitet
werden wir müssen energie erzeugung und
energieimporte and
moralisieren das heißt im klartext
schluss mit der resourcen vergeuden für
windkraft und photovoltaik sie sind
nicht krisenfest und nicht
versorgungssicher
trägt nur einen bruchteil der
installierten leistung zur versorgung
bei kernkraft nahezu
100% setzens normalisierung der
gasimporte aus russland und wenn
erforderlich eröffnung von nord stream
zwei ja natürlich sittens
laufzeitverlängerung für die noch
aktiven kernkraftwerke reaktivierung der
zuletzt stillgelegten und natürlich dem
bau neuer kernkraftwerke
wir brauchen die kernkraft für eine
saubere sichere und bezahlbare energie
und schön dass die cdu das jetzt auch
allmählich zu begreifen scheint herr
merz ihre partei die seit 16 jahren nach
der grün-roten pfeife tanzt haben wir
diese misere überhaupt erst zu verdanken
die energiewende ins nichts ist resultat
dieser politik und 16 jahre merkel und
die fortsetzung der energiewende und der
missbrauch der krise um sie noch zu
forcieren
münden im sicheren ruin die bürger
dieses landes die arbeitende bevölkerung
und der mittelstand industrie brauchen
freiheit und luft zum atmen und nicht
immer neue vorschriften und gänge lang
und schon gar nicht brauchen sie auch
noch in dieser lage das muss man sich
mal vorstellen ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz in den meisten
ländern wird das corona virus bereits
wie ein saisonales grippe virus
behandelt ohne massnahmen chaos masten
zwang und nötigung das gesetz dass sie
morgen zur abstimmung stellen wollen
macht den ausnahmezustand zur
dauereinrichtung und die grundrechts
einschränkungen zum regelfall ständig
und es ist ein armutszeugnis für die fdp
dass sie sich dafür her da nützt auch
ein kubicki nichts und aber vielleicht
und das ist so meine vermutung wollen
sie ja jetzt schon eine handhabe sich
sichern um demonstration gegen ihre
politik durch die hintertüre
desinfektion schutzes zu verbieten frau
feser das ja gar keine gelegenheit aus
um
regierungskritische demonstration in die
rechtsradikalismus ecke zu stellen was
für eine bankrotterklärung für diese
regierung welche die demonstrations- und
meinungsfreiheit mit füßen tritt
beenden sie die deutsche geisterfahrt in
der korona energie und migrationspolitik
kommen sie zurück auf den boden der
tatsachen
korrigieren sie ihre falsche politik
statt immer neue fehl entscheidungen zu
treffen ja dass das das steht ihm gut zu
gesicht der spott der grün merken sie
sich das die leute werden sich das
merken die sie hier reagieren wie dieses
land hier geradewegs an die wand fährt
durch ihre politik und wenn sie nicht
willens oder fähig sind ihren kurs zu
ändern dann treten sie bitte ab denn das
wäre das beste entlastungspaket für
unser land
alles weil die fraktionsvorsitzenden der
afg hat hier noch einmal bekräftigt dass
ja diese verständlich für den
weiterbetrieb von atomkraftwerken
eintritt
nächste rednerin hier in der aussprache
ist britta haßelmann eine von zwei
fraktionsvorsitzende der bündnisgrünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren erst mal möchte ich
mich bedanken frau präsidentin für
unsere gedenkstunde hier und ihre worte
für michael gorbatschow vielen dank
dafür ich glaube es war wichtig hier
notwendig dieses signal an diesem tag
auch zu senden und damit die
parlamentsdebatte zu eröffnen und meine
damen und herren ja wir streiten und wir
ringen heute im parlament zwischen den
demokratischen kräften
über die frage was sind die richtigen
maßnahmen was sind die lösungen sehen
die einen versäumnisse und die anderen
sehen wir tun was aber eins eint uns an
diesem morgen
das nämlich klar ist dass wir als
demokratinnen und demokraten
zusammenstehen gegen die rattenfänger
von rechts und wenn es einen eines
beweises bedurft hätte
der beitrag von alice beiden und und das
video das gerade durch social media
läuft da wünscht sich der milch ein teil
der fraktion der afg dass es noch hertha
kommt dass es noch schlimmer wird dass
die krise sich manifestiert damit sie
als ard mit ihren lügen ihrer propaganda
und ihrer menschenfeindlichkeit eine
chance für das anwachsen der ard sehen
und meine damen und herren egal woher
märz herr scholz oder britta haßelmann
stehen das werden die demokratischen
kräfte im land verhindern und darüber
bin ich froh
meine damen und herren wir führen hier
eine inhaltliche und sehr kontroversen
debatte in krisenzeiten und herr merz
ich wünsche mir dass ein blick auf die
wirklichkeit der ist zwingend notwendig
den sollten sie sich auch stellen wer
meine damen und herren hat uns in diese
zementierte abhängigkeit geführt ja der
krieg putins auf die ukraine heute nach
196 tagen ist die situation für die
menschen so schrecklich so dramatisch so
zerstörerisch das für uns feststehen
muss dass die solidarität
uneingeschränkt geht unsere
unterstützung humanitär wirtschaftlich
und auch mit waffen die sie dringend
brauchen dass wir die als deutscher
bundestag garantiert und die ukraine
wissen hier seid nicht allein wir lassen
euch nicht im stich das ist das signal
aber wie hat und das ist die krise aus
der viele andere krisen erwachsen ich
denke oft an das leid die zerstörung für
die menschen in der ukraine
aber wer hat uns in diese zementierte
abhängigkeit von russland geführt von
fossilen energien da sagt dort gerade
eine rot-grüne ich glaube ich spinne
leute der bilder besitzen sie eigentlich
sie haben 16 jahre regiert und wir
wissen dass sie es waren die den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien blockiert
haben wo sie nur konnten wir haben alles
getan auf bundesebene
und auf länderebene da wo sie
regierungsmehrheiten hatten um den
ausbau der erneuerbaren um
energieeffizienz energieeinsparung um
moderne technologien die uns daran
hindern weiterhin in die energie in die
atmosphäre zu schleudern co2 auszustoßen
und dagegen was zu tun das ist ihre
verantwortung 16 jahre unionsgeführte
regierung und tat sie das wo allgemein
nie glauben wollen helfe ich ihm
gedankenstütze wer hat eigentlich dafür
gesorgt dass der gasspeicher 20
25 15 an gazprom ging das war ihr
bundeswirtschaftsminister
es war die verantwortung von altmaier
die uns dahin geführt hat meine damen
und herren und wir hat bis zuletzt die
letzte bundesregierung hat bis zuletzt
am nord stream zwei festgehalten auch
diese große viele entscheidung ist eine
entscheidung die sie gemeinsam zu
verantworten haben während wir davor
gewarnt haben auch daran erinnert sich
heute wirklich nicht gerne jemand und
die rufe aus ihrer fraktion für ein gas
embargo soll ich ihnen die
presseberichte zeigen vermehrt sich
standen doch in der ersten reihe dabei
ich bin froh dass wir das nicht getan
haben wo wären wir denn heute der
krisenbewältigung wo gehen wir heute was
müssen wir den menschen zumuten wenn wir
uns auf dieses auf diese vielen
entscheidungen kollege hin gelassen die
kollegen asse keiner zeit
und ihre ideologische debatten führung
in hinblick auf atom die ist doch
entlarven meine damen und herren da sagt
hier einer mit großen augen nein wir
sind auch nicht für die verlängerung von
atomlaufzeiten kommt im fünften satz
aber so drei bis vier jahre oder
vielleicht bis zum ende der energiekrise
herr merz wissen sie eigentlich was das
heißt das heißt die verlängerung der
atomenergie das heißt den ausstieg vom
ausstieg den hatten sie doch schon mal
hinter sich denn sie wissen doch dass
mit nein ganz es fakt und sie sollten
sich damit beschäftigen denn drei bis
vier jahre halten die brennstäbe
überhaupt nicht sie müssten neue 3 stebe
besorgen und sagen seht ihr einen
ausstieg aus dem ausstieg und der ist
uns schon mal einmal teuer gekommen
gerade wegen ihnen und ihrer viele
entscheidungen in der regierungszeit 29
bis 213 meine damen und herren
eine debatte wird so fakten frei geführt
wie diese der stresstest der
stresstest der polizei zeigt ganz
eindeutig er rechtfertigt keine
verlängerung der atomenergie und das ist
gut so meine damen und herren es handelt
sich um eine hochrisikotechnologie
wir haben den auftrag und zwar
gesetzlich und auch durch das
bundesverfassungsgericht mit auf den weg
gegeben dass wir uns um die gefahren für
die bürgerinnen und bürger sorgen machen
müssen und was nicht geht ist dass sie
weiterhin lamentieren und polemisieren
und solche primitiven formeln wie drei
+3 +3 von anti steuer aus bayern auch
noch ernsthaft in die debatten hier ein
türen hier andreas scheuer aus der csu
ist dafür dass wir drei neue
kernkraftwerke bauen das soll ein
beitrag zur krisenbewältigung im hier
und jetzt sein wissen sie wie lange ein
bau eines atomkraftwerkes dauert
offenbar nicht aber bis bayern hat sich
das sich rumgesprochen der mann hat ja
auch nur verantwortung dafür
irgendwelche dinge in die welt zu pusten
aber sonst nichts auf die endlager frage
gibt es keine antwort gerade nicht von
cdu und csu
außerdem satz wohl nicht in bayern meine
damen und herren und deshalb lassen sie
uns zu den fakten zurückkommen wir
wollen jetzt nach was jahrelang versäumt
wurde dass nämlich die priorität auf dem
ausbau der erneuerbaren der
energieeinsparung der in denen die
effizienz liegt und daher reicht es auch
mit ihren polemisieren gegen robert
habeck denn der allen voran an der
spitze hat gerade verdammt viel zu tun
und leistet viel und ich rate und da
spricht doch aus jeder pore
haus liga-tore spricht doch der neid
wenn ich höre dass manche sagen es täte
manchen gut
ich finde es täte manchen von ihnen gut
erst zu denken dann zu sprechen
meine damen und herren wir
haben jetzt drei entlastungs paket auf
den weg gebracht und das ist doch
wirklich wichtig und notwendig denn wir
können doch nicht sagen wie weit wir
jetzt sind wie sich die krise weiter
entwickeln wird es wird viele menschen
habt treffen in unserem land das wissen
wir und wir sind längst ich am ende mit
diesen unterstützungs paketen wir sind
in krisen modus ja und wir werden vieles
tun müssen sozial abfedern in
erneuerbare energien investieren und die
ökologische und soziale transformation
der wirtschaft weiter begleiten und
werde heute zu tut als wäre die eine
maßnahme das richtige und damit wäre
alles getan streut den menschen sand in
die augen wir können doch wo das signal
ausgehen
wir nehmen ihre sorgen und ängste war
wir wissen viele menschen haben angst
vor abstieg und vorhaben und und wir
filtern das ab und ob wir und ob wir in
zwei monaten mehr tun müssen weitere
dinge auf den weg bringen müssen das
wird sich zeigen das weiß heute noch
niemand weil noch niemand weiß wohin die
krise noch geht und wie tief sie greifen
wird und deshalb ist es wichtig das
signal auszusenden
wir bauen die soziale ökologische
transformation der ausbau der
erneuerbaren mit kraft wir machen uns
unabhängig was jahrelang versäumt wurde
in sachen energieversorgung wir
versuchen gemeinsam mit wirtschaft
handwerk und die mittelstand die ja ja
ja wir tun alles dafür in dieser krise
zu stabilisieren und darum geht es im
moment und wir machen jetzt in dieser
woche die haushaltsplanberatungen die
auch ein klares signal geben auf die
frage wohin wollen wir investieren da
geht es auch um die nationalen fragen es
geht auch um die internationale
verantwortung die wir haben klimaschutz
und
natur
entwicklungsarbeit humanitäre hilfen für
die krise das ist notwendig und hier ist
jede kraftanstrengung notwendig wenn wir
nach pakistan sehen wenn wir die
hitzeentwicklung in diesem sommer in
europa ansehen auch hier bei uns dann
wissen wir was sie uns hinterlassen
haben nämlich lauter baustellen die wir
jetzt im hinblick auf die bekämpfung der
krise der klimakrise angehen müssen und
sie zeigen sich in so einer dramatik
dass wir auch im rahmen des haushaltes
hier akzente setzen müssen die unsere
internationale und nationale
verantwortung deutlich unterstreichen
das ist und gleichzeitig es mit dem
dritten entlastungspaket ein signal
gesendet dass wir menschen hier im land
die wenig haben dass wir die zielgenau
unterstützen wollen und gehen sie nicht
so darüber hin denkt ja ich höre kritik
allgemein am entlastungspaket wo sind
sie denn mit ihrer verantwortung beim
thema bürgergeld bei den menschen die
wenig haben wir machen gerade die größte
regelsatzerhöhung die es seit einführung
von hartz tier gibt und das ist der
erste schritt wir machen gleichzeitig
das wohngeld den heizkostenzuschuss die
fragen von energiepreis pauschale alles
wichtige soziale alles wichtige soziale
abfederung sie werden dazu beitragen
dass sich not lindert natürlich bleibt
es dabei dass viele menschen in einer
kritischen situation sind und wir werden
immer wieder überlegen ob die maßnahmen
die wir auf den weg bringen reichen oder
ob wir noch nachsteuern müssen wie zb
beim kleinen handwerk ob die bäckereien
fleischereien oder der kulturszene
wir müssen doch gemeinsam als parlament
das signal aussenden wir lassen euch
nicht im stich wir überlegen uns immer
wieder wo können wir ansetzen was können
wir tun und dass es verantwortliches
handeln meine damen und herren
und weil ich gerade über die
angesprochen haben die wenig haben
ich finde es im in form wie markus söder
auf kosten von beifall im bierzelt beim
gillamoos über menschen gesprochen hat
die wenig geld haben und den
grundsicherung leben mein eindruck ist
sie kennen diese lebenswirklichkeit von
menschen die arm sind überhaupt nicht
ansonsten ja ich glaube schon ich habe
lange sie noch als sozialarbeiterin
gearbeitet
ich glaube dass markus söder damit ein
zeichen ausgesendet hat ihm ist jedes
mittel recht zur parteipolitischen
profilierung
profilieren und sei es auf dem rücken
von menschen die arm sind die wenig
haben und das finde ich in form dass
sowas
mit sowas der wahlkampf eingeläutet wird
die nächsten jahre vor sich
ich finde das
unzulässig aber vielleicht muss es jeder
für sich verantworten was er da tut aber
die abwertung von menschen ist ein
mittel dem wir uns gemeinsam wirklich
sagen sollten das ist nicht unser ding
und das tun wir nicht meine damen
ich glaube ich bin gerade in
schwierigen zeiten niemand wird sagen
durch die ein oder andere maßnahme ist
die krise vorbei wir versuchen alles wir
geben alles krisenbewältigung zu machen
den ausbau der erneuerbaren
voranzubringen und uns unabhängig zu
machen und wir nehmen unsere
internationale verantwortung wahr weil
wir wissen nur gemeinsam sind wir stark
in dieser zeit die zeitenwende sozial
und nachhaltig gestalten darum geht es
jetzt meine damen und herren vielen dank
britta haßelmann co fraktionsvorsitzende
von bündnis 90 die grünen sie hat hier
mehrfach geschworen wir lassen euch
nicht und ich liebe bürger und sie hat
am anfang ihrer rede gesagt als
demokraten stehen wir zusammen sie
meinte damit im kampf gegen russland und
ob das wirklich so ist das muss man ja
in frage stellen es gibt mittlerweile
immer mehr menschen die den ausweg darin
sehen dass man die sanktionen zurück
fährt und dass man durch nord stream
zwei vielleicht das gas hierher und kann
zu diesen menschen gehört wohl auch
amira mohammed ali die ko-vorsitzende
linksfraktionen
millionen menschen in deutschland haben
angst sie haben angst vor den brief des
energieversorgers die breite verdoppelt
oder sogar verdreifacht
sie haben angst um ihren arbeitsplatz
immer mehr unternehmen sind von der
insolvenz bedroht oder sind bereits drin
und die die ein paar ersparnisse haben
die haben angst dass dieses kleine
polster von der inflation einfach
aufgefressen wird und all die vielen
millionen die keine ersparnisse haben
die wissen überhaupt nicht mehr wie sie
über diesen winter kommen soll die
aktuellen preissteigerungen die fressen
im schnitt ein ganzes monatseinkommen
pro jahr auf und das hat dramatische
folgen für die direkt betroffenen
menschen aber auch für die gesamte
deutsche wirtschaft dieser
kaufkraftverlust er wirkt jetzt schon
verheerend und herr scholz sie haben
jetzt hier in ihrer rede
sich einen guten teil der zeit an
friedrich merz abgearbeitet um zu zeigen
wer hier der tolle hecht im teich ist
ich meine das erfreut vielleicht ihre
fanbase hier im raum aber es ist der
lage in diesen ländern wirklich nicht
angemessen wo die marke
und er scheut
die werden uns die werden nicht müde zu
behaupten dass keiner allein gelassen
würde leider stimmt das nicht und das
wissen die menschen auch und es wird
eben nicht dadurch besser dass sich da
den worten an der berühmten fußballhymne
bedienen und immer wieder junge never
walk alone erklären es stimmt nicht denn
was sie hier als sogenanntes entlastungs
paket vorlegen ich muss es so sagen es
ist einfach eine frechheit und bevor ich
da ins detail gehe nur einmal die groben
zahlen angucken das neue
entlastungspaket das soll ein volumen
von 65 milliarden euro haben alle drei
entlastungs pakete sollen ein
gesamtvolumen von 96 milliarden euro
haben ob die zahlen stimmen ist übrigens
zweifelhaft aber selbst wenn sie stimmen
ist das immer noch weniger geld als ich
über nacht für das sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr einfach aus dem ärmel
gezogen haben das waren rund 100
milliarden euro dafür wo die
schuldenbremse aus selbst für die
besetzung der bevölkerung wird sie es
nicht und während die koalition sich
über die 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr über nacht einig war die
entlastung im quali bevölkerung
gestritten und gerungen wochenlang damit
man bloß nicht aus versehen jemanden
bedenkt der es ihrer meinung nach nicht
verdient hätte und auch hier mit
bestenfalls wieder gekleckert es wird
eben nicht geklotzt dabei wäre das
dringend notwendig sie konnten sich
nicht mal dass die durchringen das
maßnahmen die nachweise die inflation
gebremst haben der tank rabatt das neue
euro ticket dass die verlängert werden
in meinem wahlkreis in niedersachsen
kostet das regional ticket jetzt wieder
190 euro statt 9 euro im monat ich meine
meinte die pendler geben ihnen recht
wenn sie den salon es soll jetzt eine
nachfolgeregelung kommen ziemlich
kompliziert und vor allem soll sie über
die länder mitfinanziert werden sie
wissen aber dass viele länder das
finanziell überhaupt nicht stimmen
können das doch eine luftnummer dass die
wahrheit
und ich meine die stellen sich hier
ernsthaft hin und versuchen das als
großen sozialen wurf zu verkaufen dass
sie den rentnerinnen und rentnern nach
massivem druck von uns von der linken
von sozialverbänden von der
öffentlichkeit endlich auch das mickrige
energie geld von 300 euro zukommen
lassen wollen studierende kriegen sogar
nur 200 euro beides reicht überhaupt
nicht aus und die tatsächlichen teuro
abzufangen das doch einfach nur ein witz
kolleginnen und kollegen kommen wir mal
zum kindergeld
18 euro erhöhung 18 euro erhöhung der
wahnsinn ich meine dass ihnen das mich
peinlich
im koalitionsvertrag steht die
kindergrundsicherung drin die kommt
nicht stattdessen kommt es in
lächerliche erhöhung sich beißen dass
die entlastungspläne damit sie behaupten
können der kinder wäre auch fast drin
ich mein wissen sie eigentlich wie viel
teurer
schulhefte stifte und andere notwendige
dinge geworden sind jetzt zum
schulanfang ist das für viele familien
ein echtes problem sich das leisten zu
können das ist die wahrheit die
lebensmittelpreise sind im letzten jahr
im schnitt um 20 prozent gestiegen die
kindergelderhöhung macht mich mal zehn
prozent aus und das heißt das heißt dass
die eltern die das kindergeld kaufen und
mit dem monat zu kommen das sie jetzt
bei sich sparen müssen um ihre kinder
noch ernähren zu können das ist bereits
jetzt die realität in vielen familien
was meinen sie denn wie gut das bei
denen ankommt wenn sie immer wieder
sagen you never walk alone und kommen
wir jetzt zum bürger geht ich meine das
klingt vielleicht besser aber es ist
leider nichts anderes als hartz4 hat
vier für arme das leider wörtlich
gemeint die erhöhung von 50 euro ist
nicht mal der inflationsausgleich nicht
mal ansatzweise das ist in wirklichkeit
überhaupt keine erhöhung die menschen in
grundsicherung werden weiter von ihrer
politik abgehängt das ist die wahrheit
und was sagen sie all den vielen die
seit jahren gezwungen sind bei der tafel
an zu stehen und die jetzt nicht mal
mehr dort genug lebensmittel kriegen
weil die tafeln auch unter druck sind
stellen sie sich daneben und so haben
sie den schon erwogen ich glaube nicht
dass betrifft inzwischen schon zwei
millionen menschen in unserem land die
müssen zur tafel gehen die tendenz ist
steigt laut dem forschungsinstitut für
wärmeschutz in münchen müssen menschen
in schlecht gedämmten wohnungen bei den
aktuellen preisen bereits und
energiekosten von rund 4500 euro pro
jahr rechnen letztes jahr waren das noch
1800 die kosten haben sich mehr als
verdoppelt in einfamilienhäuser auch
wenn sie gedämmt sind steigen die
energiekosten von 2800 auf
7200 euro pro jahr diese preis explosion
die muss gestoppt werden aber leider tun
sie das nicht und ihre angekündigte
strompreis bremse ist leider jetzt schon
eine luftnummer einmal weil die teuerung
eben nicht nur den strombereich
betreffen sondern den gesamten
energiebereich aber vor allem weil diese
strompreis bremse nur dann kommen soll
wenn sie gegenfinanziert wird über eine
über den steuer die wiederum davon
abhängt dass die eu-kommission dafür
grünes licht gibt andere länder haben
das längst ein gefühl dann über gewinnt
steuerung verstecken sie sich hinter
brüssel wie man sie sagen erst wenn es
in brüssel nicht klappt dann wird eine
nationale regelung erwogen ich meine sie
tun ja das hat die lösung dieser
probleme noch ewig zeit nein die
menschen brauchen jetzt die
unterstützung
und darum wären auch direktzahlungen
jetzt wichtig die wirklich wirkung
entfalten wir fordern mindestens 125
euro pro monat also 1500 euro pro jahr
für jeden haushalt mit kleinem und
mittleren einkommen denn der
kaufkraftverlust ist vergeben immer mehr
betriebe bäckereien friseure die die
preise auf unter steigenden kosten
erhöhen mussten die sehen dass ihnen die
kunden wegbrechen weil sie einfach nicht
mehr das geld haben da hinzugehen der
chef des ifo institutes clemens fuest
der sagte über die maßnahmen der
bundesregierung dass sie die rezession
nicht verhindert werden in diesem winter
einfach nicht nehmen das urteil das
institut für deutsche wirtschaft rechnet
damit dass es bei den steigenden preisen
300.000 zusätzliche arbeitslose im jahr
2023 geben wird ich meine haben wir den
mitarbeitern der jobcenter schon durch
gestellt was ihr den verzweifelten
menschen von ihnen ausrichten sollen
never walk alone man sagen sie den sind
trost irgendwann kommt vielleicht mal
eine strompreis bremse wenn brüssel
mitspielt das reicht nicht kolleginnen
und kollegen dieser energie war der muss
reguliert werden das ist die wahrheit
ich meine wenn man einmal ihn hat dass
der markt ist nicht richtet dann doch
jetzt wir brauchen eine funktionierende
staatliche preisaufsicht und wir
brauchen eben auch einen preis beckel
für die gesamte energie für die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher das ist
dringend notwendig
in frankreich wurde ein preis deckel
eingeführt da übernimmt der staat die
differenz zwischen den festgelegten
verbrauchspreis und den tatsächlichen
marktpreis warum geht das nicht bei uns
und ja ich weiß ja ich weiß ja die
antwort dafür ist angeblich kein geld da
denn es gibt ja die schuldenbremse das
lieblingskind von herrn lindner und ich
möchte ihnen mal sagen wenn sie trotz
dieser historischen krise lieber an
ihrem fetisch schuldenbremse festhalten
wollen anstatt zu verhindern dass immer
größere teil der bevölkerung in die
armut getrieben werden dann ist das
einfach nur verantwortungsvoll wie bock
dieser historischen krise die
bevölkerung in ihrer breite trifft nicht
einmal darüber nachdenken die
vermögenssteuer wieder einzuführen wie
spd und grüne das noch im wahlprogramm
hatten dann ist auch das einfach nur
verantwortungslos ich meine wenn nicht
jetzt wann dann bitte
in dieser lage in der von allen
solidarität erwartet wird in denen
angeblich allerdings gürtel enger
schnallen sollen nicht dafür zu sorgen
dass diejenigen mit dem weitesten gürtel
denen es überhaupt nicht weh tun würde
wenn sie ein bisschen enger schnallen
würden die teilweise ihr vermögen der
krise noch sagt vermehren konnten die
multi millionäre milliardäre wenn sie
jetzt nicht dafür sorgen dass die sich
zumindest ein stück weit angemessen an
den krisenkosten beteiligen dann fällt
mir wirklich absolut nichts mehr dazu
einfach inakzeptabel ist unklar das
nicht
natürlich darf man bei alldem nicht
vergessen dass die preis explosion durch
den russischen angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine verursacht worden dieser angriff
krieg der kann nicht akzeptiert werden
man musste darauf reagieren wir als
linke unterstützen die sanktionen gegen
putins machtapparat gegen die mächtigen
oligarchischen gegen die russische
rüstungsindustrie
was wir aber kritisieren das sind
sanktionen die hauptsächlich die
russische bevölkerung treffen und den
deutschland in europa im globalen süden
mehr schaden anrichten als bei denen man
eigentlich schaden sollten nämlich
putins kriegsmaschinerie wir stellen
aber fest die kriegsmaschinerie rollt
unbeeindruckt von europäischen
sanktionen leider weiter in ländern des
globalen südens gibt es bereits
ernsthafte versorgungslücken weil sie
beim weltweiten preiskampf um das erdgas
eben nicht mithalten können und auch
hier bei uns drohen weitere extreme
preissteigerungen ebenfalls
versorgungslücken beides gut zum
wegbrechen ganzer industriezweige führen
das darf man nicht geschehen lassen
kolleginnen kollegen
und darum
fordern wir von der bundesregierung
folgen es muss alles unternommen werden
um auf diplomatischen wege einen
sofortigen waffenstillstand zu erreichen
damit friedensverhandlungen mit denen
können dieser krieg muss so schnell wie
möglich ändern und zweitens
sie müssen mit russland in verhandlungen
über die gaslieferungen treten und die
versorgungssicherheit zu gewährleisten
das erwartet die bevölkerung zu recht
ich nehme sie beim wort herr scholz die
haben gesagt die sanktionen dürfen
europa nicht härter treffen als russland
bitte handeln sie mir sprechen danke
haben ihrer mohammed ali die
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
hat dem kanzler seinen spruch
entgegengehalten you never walk alone
und am einzelnen beispielen
dargestellt dass er das mal zu den
menschen sagen soll die haben unteren
drittel leben und das paket was die
bundesregierung geschnürt hat ist ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein
gerade zum beispiel bei der sozialen
grundsicherung 50 euro soll da ja mehr
kommen aber erst im januar das ganze
nennt sich dann bürgergeld 500 euro
schwer nicht so rinner christian dürr
der fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
wie einige von ihnen auch hatte ich am
sonntag die gelegenheit mit dem
ukrainischen ministerpräsidenten den es
mit leid zu sprechen und er hat mir noch
einmal
geschildert darf in sehr eindringlichen
worten was zurzeit das ergebnis dieses
angriffskrieges russlands auf die
ukraine ist und vor mohammed ali man
müsse mit russland jetzt mal in
verhandlungen treten man müsste mit
denen man reden
wissen sie was alle telefone sind immer
offen aber die wahrheit ist russland
will genau das was gerade passiert auch
mit den menschen der ukraine das ist
kein versehen russischer politik es ist
absicht russischer politik dass menschen
in der ukraine sterben meine damen und
herren das ist das durch ehrlichkeit
das ist das politische spiel
und wir spüren die finanziellen
auswirkungen ich komme darauf gleich zu
sprechen während in der ukraine jeden
tag menschen sterben ihr zuhause
verlieren oder das land verlassen müssen
ich habe
ministerpräsident michail wie viele von
ihnen auch in diesen gesprächen die
solidarität auch der bundesrepublik
deutschland noch einmal zum ausdruck
gebracht und zur einordnung dessen was
passiert
russland wladimir putin führt einen
physischen krieg gegen die menschen in
der ukraine aber er führt eben auch ein
krieg mit nahrungsmitteln und mit
energie gegen die gesamte welt und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass der
westen weiter zusammen steht meine damen
und herren deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass die nato derzeit gestärkt wird
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir auch
mit unseren transatlantischen freunden
in diesen tagen auch was das thema
waffenlieferung betrifft auch was das
thema finanzielle unterstützung der
ukraine betrifft zusammenstehen der
zusammenhalt der westlichen
staatengemeinschaft ist die ganz
zentrale antwort in diesen schwierigen
tagen für die gesamte welt liebe
kollegin gelegen
von ich will
als erstes auf das thema was in vielen
reden heute morgen schon natürlich
unterstrichen worden ist nämlich die
energieversorgung zu sprechen kommen die
oberste prämisse in den nächsten monaten
ist die preise an den energiemärkten
müssen sinken diese preise meine damen
und herren das muss man sehr klar
aussprechen sind für niemanden derzeit
zu tragen nicht für die privaten
haushalte in deutschland nicht für die
unternehmen nicht nur wenig energie
unternehmen in der energieintensiven
unternehmen nicht zu tragen sondern
selbst der einzelhändler um die ecke
kann sich 20 fach höhere stromkosten
schlicht und einfach nicht leisten
aktuell ist es etwa das zehnfache aber
selbst das führt natürlich zu
katastrophalen entwicklung im gerade in
mittelständischen unternehmen meine
damen und herren ja das ist die
ausgangssituation und herr kollege merz
ist fand ihre aussage sehr interessant
weil wir ja auch darüber sprechen müssen
um für die zukunft zu lernen was in den
letzten jahren passiert ist sie haben
gesagt diese regierung trägt nicht
allein die verantwortung für die
abhängigkeit russlands
wissen sie was diese bundesregierung
stellt sich der verantwortung die
verantwortung in jedem fall trägt diese
bundesregierung und nicht aber sie ist
gebet um jetzt verantwortung zu
übernehmen und das tun wir liebe
kollegen kollegen
das ist die abhängigkeit russlands vom
erdgas und dass es da keine leichten
antworten gibt haben die reden heute
morgen deutlich gesagt herr merz ich
will auch daran erinnert was sie am 10
märz diesen jahres gesagt haben sie
waren der erste politiker aus der
unionsfraktion der gesagt hat man muss
die
erdgaslieferung die energielieferungen
aus russland sofort einstellen das ist
das herz was sie am 10 märz gesagt hat
das ist das was sie anziehen mehr zurück
niemand ist glücklich über diese
abhängigkeit sie ist eine ökonomische
katastrophe und auch geopolitisch zu uns
eine herausforderung aber herr mehr
zubereitet zu dieser einfachen antworten
gibt es nicht weder das einstellen der
erdgaslieferung noch jetzt irgendwelche
deckel ich komme darauf gleich zu
sprechen sind die perfekte antwort diese
bundesregierung ich wiederhole es stellt
sich dieser verantwortung die
vorgängerregierung verursacht haben
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
und jetzt will ich sagen was wir tun es
ist immer die gasanlage viel gesprochen
wir werden jetzt die mehrwertsteuer auf
diese gas umlage noch einmal senken und
die zielgerichtete
ausrichten meine damen und herren denn
es ist natürlich für viele kunden für
viele unternehmen geradezu ein
überraschen sie wussten bisher gar nicht
von wem der lieferant das erdgas bezogen
hat ist es doch niemand verantwortlich
zu machen kein unternehmen kann
mittelständler dass russisches erdgas
über seinen versorger bezogen hat und
jetzt in dramatische preissteigerungen
kommt deswegen sollten wir dort eine
umlage das ist das thema gasmarkt aber
ich komme auf den strommarkt zu sprechen
der hier auch viel besprochen worden ist
meine damen und herren es
ist kein geheimnis dass auch in der
frage der weiternutzung der kernenergie
meine parteien der auffassung dazu hat
auch was die drei bestehenden
kernkraftwerke betrifft aber genauso
wichtig ist es dass wir jetzt an diesem
strommarkt etwas tun und deswegen ist
die entscheidung des
koalitionsausschusses sich für eine
strompreis bremse nicht nur einzusetzen
auf europäischer ebene sondern
gegebenenfalls
national auf diesen schritt zu gehen das
bestehende system der eeg um david zu
nutzen damit die strompreise in
deutschland für alle menschen für alle
unternehmen nach unten gehen das ist die
richtige antwort in dieser krise auch
wenn sie ordnungspolitisch nicht leicht
ist das sage ich ganz offen aber es ist
die richtige antwort in dieser krise
dass die strompreise so runter gehen
meine damen und herren es unendlich
richtig als die klage märkte und an die
unternehmen in deutschland
und herr merz was schlagen sie denn vor
dem die burg problembeschreibung auch
die abhängigkeit von russland da sind
wir einer meinung aber was haben sie
denn vorgeschlagen für den strommarkt
haben sie sehr konkret vorgeschlagen sie
waren ja verzug spitze ich habe mich
gefragt beim lesen des papiers ob es
bisweilen auch mit der die lüfter um
zusammenhängt sie haben vorgeschlagen
für den strommarkt das spanische modell
sie sagen dort ein gaspreis deckel an
der stellung das und erdgas soll aus dem
strommarkt herausgenommen werden wir
wissen übrigens gar wir sehen gerade was
in spanien passiert in spanien
finanzieren die spanischen
steuerzahlerin steuerzahler gerade den
stromexport nach frankreich meine damen
und herren um den sturm an der stelle
billiger zu machen das kann doch kein
modell für deutschland sein dass unsere
steuerzahler dann am ende des tages
subventionierten strom bezahlen und das
über den bundeshaushalt haben jetzt das
ist keine option für deutschland die
strompreis bremse ist die richtige
antwort und deswegen hat die
bundesregierung diese auch getroffen
und zweitens seien gasmarkt beim gas
markt schlagen sie in ihrem papier von
der zugspitze vor ein gaspreis deckel
wissen sie werden gerade verteidigt hat
vor mohammed ali von der linkspartei
also sie sagen am besten soll das über
den bundeshaushalt geregelt werden der
bundeshaushalt wird dann die differenz
dieses deckels und vergleich zum
marktpreis tragen meine damen und herren
mit ihren vorschlägen sogar ihren sie
eine ist nämlich dass die
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler die
gestiegenen energiepreise decken können
ich sagen aller kleid ja wie werden an
diesen märkten veränderung vornehmen
aber ein spurt zur weiter zu der staat
die gemeinschaft der steuerzahlerinnen
steuerzahler der kann diese
energiepreise nicht einfach schultern
das würde die staatliche gemeinschaft in
deutschland überfordern diese wahrheit
muss man aussprechen alles andere hat
ist eine illusion ich will das deutlich
an dieser stelle sagen die kollegen
und ich habe schon gesagt putin hat
diese krise ausgelöst aber
wir wissen doch alle dass der reformstau
in diesem land angesichts dieser krise
wie unter einem brennglas deutlich wird
meine damen und herren deutschland ist
bei der digitalisierung hinterher wir
sind beim klimaschutz hinterher wir
haben viel geld dafür ausgegeben den
letzten jahrzehnten aber wenig erreicht
am ende des tages die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der bundesrepublik
deutschland ist gefährdet wegen zu
starker abhängigkeiten es muss mal
gesagt werden wir sind in deutschland in
den letzten zwei jahrzehnten aus vielen
dingen ausgestiegen meine damen und
herren aus vielen technologien
ausgestiegen aber wir hätten zum
gleichen zeitpunkt mit aller macht auch
in neue technologien einsteigen müssen
meine damen und herren der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energie ist nicht in dem
maße vorangekommen aber vor allen dingen
der ausbau das eher konventionelle
energiekette ersetzen können meine damen
und herren wo war denn der einsatz
seiner zeit für den ausbau der
stromnetze wo war denn da einsatz seiner
zeit für die grundlastfähigkeit auch
erneuerbaren energien das muss doch die
zukunft zwar ein co2 neutrales aber
gleichzeitig trat verfahren die
viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
meine damen und herren da sind die
fehler gemacht worden für sieben
erneuerbare anzeigenblatt im
landschaftsbild vor uns sind die
erneuerbaren die wirtschaftliche
grundlage in der zukunft der
bundesrepublik deutschland liebe
kollegen kollegen noch einmal deutlich
zu sagen
und ich komme zu dem neben den dingen
die wir an den märkten tun müssen ich
habe das unterstrichen ich komme zum
entlastungspaket zum dritten
entlastungspaket denen das der
koalitionsausschuss am wochenende
erarbeitet hat als
erstes der inflationsausgleich für die
arbeiten menschen in diesem land steht
an oberster stelle in diesem paket und
das richtigerweise und auch da muss ich
noch einmal auf das eingehen was sie
lieber herr kollege merz in ihrer rede
gerade gesagt haben sie haben gerade in
richtung der bundesregierung behauptet
das stünde ja eben gesetz das würde
sozusagen ja eh automatisch also wir
hätten gesetzestext aufgeschrieben ich
würde ganz gerne eine wette eingehen ich
möchte den paragrafen
einkommensteuergesetz gerne sehen herr
merz wurde das was sie behauptet haben
drin steht die wahrheit ist doch die
union hatte nie den mut liga abbau der
kalten progression ihnen das
einkommenssteuergesetz zu schreiben die
wahrheit ist das was ihr behauptet ist
schlicht falsch ja andere europäische
länder machen das deutschland macht es
bedauerlicherweise bisher nicht und weil
das nicht der fall ist wird diese ampel
koalition die hart arbeitende mitte in
deutschland entlasten ein ganz wichtiges
signal des koalitionsausschusses wie
ihre kolleginnen und kollegen
und
wir werden natürlich auch um diejenigen
kümmern die nicht im arbeitsleben sind
um die rentnerinnen und rentner und die
menschen in ausbildung um die studieren
und studierende mit einer weiteren
energie pauschalen wir werden das
kindergeld erhöhen wir werden die home
office pauschalen im steuerrecht
entfristen wir senken die umsatzsteuer
auf gas nicht erwähnte ist von wir
setzen den co2 preis die erhöhung zum
ersten januar aus damit die menschen und
unternehmen nicht zusätzlich belastet
werden die steuerliche absetzbarkeit der
rentenbeiträge das thema
doppelbesteuerung von unionsgeführten
bundesregierung nie gelöst wird diese
bundesregierung lösen meine damen und
herren und es wird ein bundesweites
nahverkehrs ticket geben und da ist ja
manche bundesländer in deutschland gibt
in denen die union entweder den
ministerpräsident gestellt oder mit in
der bundesregierung ist habe ich
folgenden appell für sie anstatt hier
hin und her zu reden unterstützen sie
den verkehrsminister volker wissing bei
diesem revolutionären vorhaben ein
digitales deutschland ticken bundesweit
anzubieten da müssen die länder jetzt
über ihren schatten springen wäre eine
revolution für unseren öffentlichen
personennahverkehr genau das zu tun
meine damen und herren
also es sind die familien der mitte aber
auch diejenigen die es schwer haben die
von diesen dritten entlastungspaket
entsprechend profitieren meine damen und
herren und jetzt habe ich mir auch an
der stelle noch mal angeschaut was auf
der zugspitze so passiert ist und was in
den letzten tagen gesagt worden ist sagt
ja das waren richtige schritte ich
anerkenne dass sie sagen auch entlastung
kalte progression und manches mehr sind
richtige schritte den wir als
regierungskoalition gehen ich habe mir
angeschaut was sie fordern sie haben es
eben hier nochmal wiederholt das untere
drittel der einkommen eine pauschale von
1000 euro das macht etwa 16 milliarden
euro für den bundeshaushalt für jedes
kind einmal noch mal 1000 euro das sind
etwa fünf milliarden für den
bundeshaushalt und der vorgeschlagene
gaspreis decke meine damen und herren
der wird etwa 38 milliarden euro für den
bundeshaushalt machen ich will mich ich
will mich nicht auf den euro festlegen
meine damen und herren ich habe das aber
mal zusammengerechnet was sie
offensichtlich nicht getan haben wir
reden hier über 50 milliarden euro
zusätzliche belastung für den etat für
den bundeshaushalt meine damen und
herren ich frage wer soll das bezahlen
sie fordern einen gaspreis deckel
anstelle einer umlage ich frage wer soll
das bezahlen
sie fordern eine subventionierung der
gasverstromung als unionsfraktion
anstelle der strompreis bremse ich frage
wer soll das bezahlen meine damen und
herren der gaspreis deckel wo sie
eigentlich sind mit der linkspartei soll
aus dem haushalt finanziert wird aber
die sind wenigstens so ehrlich und sagen
dass sie die schuldenbremse abschaffen
wollen meine damen und herren die
stabilität unseres landes ist in diesen
tagen gefragt und alles das will ich zum
schluss sagen darf auf gar keinen fall
passieren indem wir den bundeshaushalt
selber überfordern indem wir eine
expansive geldpolitik und ausgabepolitik
am ende des tages machen das darf auf
gar keinen fall passieren dass wir die
inflation durch den haushalt zusätzlich
anreiz und frau präsidentin ich komme
jetzt zum schluss und will noch eine
anmerkung machen in aller kürze und da
habe ich mir angeschaut was sie noch
vorschlagen sie schlagen vor einer
abwrackprämie für haushaltsgeräte das
klingt ja erst mal nett aber ich frage
mich
welcher ökonomen in der gesamten welt
ist zurzeit auf der empfehlung dass er
sagt wir müssten in zeiten der inflation
nachfrage politik zu machen anstatt
angebotspolitik ich habe vorhin erwähnt
was die bundeswehr alles macht aber mit
verlaub herr merz ökonomisch zentimeter
gerade auf der vierspurig laufen sie
doch falsch in zeiten der inflation in
zeiten der inflation muss man doch
angebotspolitik machen planungs
beschleunigung
die giga betze gigabit netze die bildung
investitionen in die
verkehrsinfrastruktur mehr
freihandelsabkommen und mehr
einwanderung in den deutschen
arbeitsmarkt meine damen und herren
ökonomisch und ich hätte fast nicht mehr
glaubt dass ich das jemals aussprechen
werde ökonomisch sind so manche
jungsozialisten in der spd zurzeit markt
wird sich dann dort wächst als die
unionsfraktion im deutschen bundestag
ich danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
ein angriffslustiger fraktionschef der
fdp christian
die schuldenbremse steht das ist das
wichtigste war zunächst auch in seiner
rede für die liberalen offensichtlich
dass mit den atomkraftwerken das ist
dumm gelaufen ein bisschen gehört am
dienstag noch im morgenmagazin gesagt
wir müssen die laufzeit verlängern sonst
drohen absurd hohe kosten davon war
heute nicht die rede sondern er hat
gesagt wir sind ja halt
unterschiedlicher meinung was soll er
auch tun in einer koalitionsregierung wo
die beiden anderen partner anderer
meinung sind alexander dobrindt jetzt
der landesgruppenchef
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin der
bundeskanzler sie haben heute wieder den
begriff der zeitenwende bedient es
gehört inzwischen
zuständigen regelmäßigkeit ihre reden
aber es gibt jetzt einen entscheidenden
unterschied bei ihrer zeitenwende rede
vom 27 februar da hatten sie die
unterstützung weil sie zu notwendigen
entscheidungen bereit waren diese
unterstützung haben sie in dem moment
verloren als sie aufgehört haben diese
zeitenwende zu gestalten das ist derzeit
offen
der bundeswirtschaftsminister
habeck sie haben uns im sommer
mitgeteilt dass sie die energiedebatte
entlang der fakten führen wörtliches
zitat fakt ist wir haben ein gas problem
kein strom problem mit fakten hat dieser
spruch schon mal rein gar nichts zu tun
habe
sie haben am montag die vorstellung des
stresstests mit den
übertragungsnetzbetreibern
gemacht die haben dabei sehr deutlich
darauf hingewiesen dass die
energiesituation in deutschland massiv
angespannt ist die fachleute haben
erklärt dass eine geordnete
abschaltung von verbrauchern ein
mögliches szenario ist geordnete
abschaltung von verbrauchern das heißt
übersetzt nichts anderes als regionaler
blackouts sind denkbar die
netzsicherheit sei nur durch strom aus
dem ausland zum gewähren ob es aber zu
diesem zeitpunkt zur verfügung steht ist
vollkommen unsicher und die fachleute
haben ihnen ins stammbuch geschrieben
dass die drei kernkraftwerke einen
beitrag leisten um die last unterdeckung
zu vermeiden er habe was ist da
eigentlich so schwer daran zu verstehen
wer bei dieser analyse
netz sicherheit gefährdet regionaler
blackouts denkbar zu der entscheidung
kommt die drei kernkraftwerke nicht
weiter betreiben zu lassen
der handelt nicht entlang der fakten
sondern der handel schlicht
verantwortungslos das ist die wahre
interessant oder in dem zusammenhang
übrigens auch das dann am montag kurz
bevor sie ihre pressekonferenz gemacht
haben den stresstest präsentiert haben
auch der bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner öffentlich mitgeteilt hat dass
die drei kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen
sollen zitat in diesen zeiten sollten
alle möglichkeiten genutzt werden den
strompreis für die menschen und die
betriebe zu reduzieren was ist da
eigentlich so schwer daran zu verstehen
wir brauchen mehr kapazitäten im
strommarkt um die preise zu reduzieren
sie nehmen aber in einer zeit der
größten energieknappheit
kapazitäten aus dem netz sie schicken
sie in die reserve und das in einer zeit
wo die menschen schon am ende mit ihren
reserven sind und die preise nicht mehr
bezahlen können
der bundesminister haarweg sie
ignorieren die ergebnisse dieses
stresstests sie riskieren blick auf sie
setzen bürger und betriebe in diesem
land einem echten massiven stresstest
aus und das alles das alles damit ihre
grünen wahlkampf kollegen in
niedersachsen ihr schönes plakat bei
atomkraft nicht abhängen müssen das ist
die wahrheit hinter ihrer entscheidung
serie der bundeskanzler
den grünen energieminister in
deutschland die grüne parteitags basis
wichtiger ist als die
versorgungssicherheit unseres landes
dann sollten sie als bundeskanzler
diesen wirtschaftsminister den stecker
ziehen das ist ihre aufgabe stellen
herr bundeskanzler sie haben heute ja
auch über die lng terminals gesprochen
wir hoffen übrigens dass sie damit
erfolgreich sein werden aber dann
erklären sie uns doch bitte mal an
dieser stelle wie kommt es eigentlich
zustande dass die vereinbarungen die ihr
wirtschaftsminister mit dem land katar
getroffen hat über steuerungsgruppe über
arbeitsgruppen die die
energiezusammenarbeit und die lieferung
von energie aus katar organisieren
sollen schriftlich vereinbart dass diese
arbeitsgruppen nach auskunft des
bundeswirtschaftsministerium bis heute
kein einziges mal getagt haben können
sie erklären was das mit einer
vorsorglichen
energieversorgung in deutschland zu tun
hat sie reden über allen vier
bundesminister habe hat aus katar keinen
einzigen kubikmeter gas mitgebracht aber
hat den menschen haut meist sand in die
augen gestreut das ist doch das was
dahinter steht
sie haben sehr leidenschaftlich hier an
dieser stelle herr bundeskanzler auch
über die gasspeicher in deutschland
gesprochen sie haben darüber gesprochen
dass sie nicht gefüllte worden wären ja
der größte gasspeicher reden ist
deswegen nicht gefüllt worden weil er an
russland verkauft worden ist aber für
hasselmann nur zur aufklärung falls sie
sich nicht daran erinnern ja dieser
verkauf war falsch aber derjenige der
den verkauf zugelassen hat das war der
bundeswirtschaftsminister sigmar gabriel
von der spd und niemand anderes
es scheinen ja so manche irrtümer hier
auch weiter zu gehen der bundeskanzler
hat den brief angesprochen dass er sich
für flüssiggas terminal ist besonders
eingesetzt hätte auch gerade gegen den
über den vereinigten staaten von amerika
und sich darüber beschwert dass dieser
brief dann an die öffentlichkeit durch
gesprochen wurde nummer zum hinweis
erstens die deutsche umwelthilfe hat
diesen brief veröffentlicht und zweitens
den diesen brief haben sie ihr
bundeskanzler angeboten eine milliarde
zusätzlich für den bau von terminals
auszugeben wenn die vereinigten staaten
von amerika auf sanktionen gegen
140 tten herr bundeskanzler die frage
ist doch nicht wer hat ihn durch
gestorben die frage ist ob sie vor mit
die hörner darüber gesprochen haben sich
da und hier
sie rühmen sich hier ja von seiten der
ampel gegenseitig und für ihr neues
entlastungspaket 300 euro für rentner
dass die erkenntnis reichlich spät kamen
geschenkt wir unterstützen diese
anliegen wohngeld kinderzuschlag hat
hier durchaus sinnvolle maßnahmen aber
was ist eigentlich mit denjenigen
menschen die sich nicht auf
transferzahlungen diesem land stützen
können die mittleren die kleinen
einkommen die verweisen sie hier dürfe
gerade gehört auf die kalte progression
die verweisen sie darauf dass sie daher
großzügig jetzt im nächsten jahr
entlastungen vorsehe ich gebe ihnen mal
ein zitat von
bundesfinanzminister aus dem august wir
sollten diese demokratisch nicht
legitimierten einnahmen zurückgeben das
ist kein gönnerhafte akt sondern in
mehrfacher hinsicht geboten und diese
rückgabe dieser nicht legitimierten
einnahmen wollen sie jetzt den menschen
als große entlastung verkaufen das ist
definitiv keine kluge politik an dieser
stelle
der mittelstand ist ganz besonders von
dieser aktuellen situation betroffen wir
erleben aktuell bereits die ersten
insolvenzen das institut für
wirtschaftsforschung rechnet ihnen vor
dass die insolvenzen im märz deutlich
ansteigen werden teile des mittelstands
die kleine betriebe die handwerker die
echten unter diesen lasten der
explodierenden energiepreise und sie
wollen nicht ausreichend gegensteuern
die energiepreis explosion wird wenn sie
nicht bekämpft wird nur zu einer
einzigen frage bei den mittelständlern
den handwerkern den kleinen unternehmen
führen abwanderung oder einstellen des
geschäftsbetriebs das ist die
alternative vor den diese menschen und
unternehmen stehen und sehr geehrter
herr
bundeswirtschaftsminister sie rechnen ja
anders als die wirtschaftsinstitute
offensichtlich nicht mit einer
insolvenzwelle zumindest haben sie uns
das gestern abend über die medien
mitgeteilt aber sie können sich
vorstellen dass bestimmte branchen
wörtlich nicht mehr produzieren oder
einfach aufhören zu verkaufen bei dem
besten willen und mit verlaub herr
minister es ist den menschen scheißegal
wie sie das nennen wenn sie arbeitslos
werden aber sie sind nicht egal wenn sie
nichts dagegen unternehmen
dieser stelle
herr kollege die redezeit war
herr dr sie haben uns mit unserem
programm auf der zugspitze an vielen
stellen hier zitiert ich frage mal
umgekehrt an der stelle wie halten sie
es denn eigentlich in dieser ampel
koalition mit ihren anliegen sie selber
haben angesprochen sie werden ja dafür
dass die kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen spd
und grüne sind dagegen sie wollen ja die
schuldenbremse einhalten spd und grüne
stellen das tagtäglich in frage sie
behaupten sie wollen entlastungen für
bürger und betriebe offensichtlich war
sie mit spd und grünen nicht zu machen
mittelstand schützen ihr thema fällt
offensichtlich in dieser koalition aus
den ländlichen raum haben sie adressiert
wollen sie unterstützen diese regierung
macht politik gegen die ländlichen raum
technologieoffenheit was es mit dem
verbrennungsmotor sie können sich am
schluss nicht durchsetzen dass er mit
alternativen kraftstoffen reiter
betrieben wird mal ganz ehrlich gesagt
herr dürr was machen sie eigentlich in
dieser koalition in dieser links neben
oper zahlung blick smillie gelben
koalition das ist die wahl die
alexander dobrindt der landesgruppenchef
der csu griff vor allen dingen robert
habeck an wir haben einen gas problem
kein strom problem dieses zitat von habe
hat er genüsslich immer wieder
vorgetragen er hat dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister vorgeworfen
mit der entscheidung über die
atomkraftwerke verantwortungslos zu
handeln sie riskieren blackouts damit
ihre wahlkampf kollegen in niedersachsen
ihr wahlplakaten bei atomkraft weiter
plakatieren können das ist die wahrheit
herr bundeskanzler sie sollten diesen
wirtschaftsminister den stecker ziehen
nächster redner jetzt trat natürlich der
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd der
wählerinnen und wähler der regierung das
vertrauen ausgesprochen freiheit
gerechtigkeit und nachhaltigkeit
bei uns und in europa zu stärken das war
kein irrtum des souveräns oder ein
betriebsunfall der demokratie wie manche
versuchen uns einzureden
oder bei zu texten die mehrheit der
menschen wollte diese regierung sie
wollte kompetenz erfahrung und
seriösität im bundeskanzleramt sie
wollte olaf scholz und wir
sozialdemokratische zahl demokraten sind
stolz dass er einer von uns sitzt
meine meine fraktion meine damen und
herren will dieses vertrauen im
kommenden haushaltsjahr tief verankert
um arbeit zu sichern und den klimawandel
und die pandemie zu bewältigen brauchen
wir ein verantwortliches gemeinwesen und
eine gerechte politik dafür wird sich
die spd bundestagsfraktion in den
nächsten wochen einsetzen und es wird in
der zweiten und dritten lesung ein guter
aus als seien das sagen wir heute zu
meine damen und herren und es geht um
mehr
ja vor dem hintergrund alter und neu
entfesselter kriege brauchen wir
militärische sicherheit die zugleich in
der täglichen suche nach frieden
eingebettet bleiben muss
diplomatie
diplomatie meine damen und herren und
der versuch spannungen zu mindern sind
keine prinzipien von gestern sondern
aktueller denn je das hat die
bundestagspräsident leute in ihrer
würdigung von präsident gorbatschow noch
mal nachhaltig beschrieben wir stehen in
dieser tradition liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wenn ich sage eine politik die
das innere und äußere zu verbessern
sucht dann braucht man ernsthaftigkeit
und kompetenz und keine beliebigkeit
kollege merz und ich würde gerne an drei
beispiele aus den letzten wochen
erinnern noch im juli haben sie eine
steuerliche erleichterung für alle
gefordert auch für große vermögen und
dann drehte sich plötzlich der wind in
der innenpolitik und dann haben sie
gesagt na ja vielleicht muss das untere
drittel auch bedacht denn herr kollege
merz ist es alles heiße luft sie hätten
den beweis antreten können vor einigen
monaten als es um den mindestlohn
gegangen ist da haben sie sich enthalten
ein tatkräftiges jahr mehr erforderlich
gewesen
und ich kann es im raum für meine
fraktion wagen in dresden gewesen doch
profitieren am ersten oktober
35.000 beschäftigte alleine von diesem
mindestlohn und es hätte sich gehört
wenn man meint ein soziales herz zu
haben zuzustimmen und hier nicht nur im
in beliebigkeit sich zu verheddern
sondern letztlich zu sagen ja das machen
wir und das ist die richtige
entscheidend meine damen und herren
und im märz haben sie einen kompletten
die verstopft für russisches gas hier
das wort geredet und ich frage sie ja
märz wiese in die speicherstände heute
aus wie sehr der herbst und der winter
für die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
aus es tut mir leid ihre
energiepolitische weitsicht geht gegen
null auch heute der kollege merz
und dann haben sie
im juni
ich kann es nicht verschweigen sich für
ein eingreifen der nato stark gemacht
wenn atomkraftwerke in der ukraine
angegriffen werden und leider wie andere
auch können sie sich offensichtlich
nicht mehr vorstellen dass es wenigstens
noch die chance für diplomatie und
alternativen geben muss als nur das
militärische und die vereinten nationen
haben das bewiesen der generalsekretär
der vereinten nationen oder grossi der
chef der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde ich danke den
mitarbeitern die namen meiner fraktion
der internationalen atomenergiebehörde
die in die ukraine gereist sind und
sozusagen ein schutzschild versuchen
aufzubauen gegen die weiteren angriffe
auf dieses atomkraftwerk und herr merz
sie meinen sie müssten hier ein
kronzeuge nein kronzeugen die man ja
schätzen kann mit einem langen zitat
bedienen
professor herfried münkler hat im jahre
2002 in einer vielzahl seiner
publikationen und bücher und ich zitiere
der klassische zwischenstaatliche krieg
ist ein historisches auslaufmodell
prognostiziert und da finde ich sollte
man sich mal überlegen ob
wissenschaftliche vergesslichkeit und
besserwisserei hier zu einem zitat
dienst lieber kollege merz deswegen sage
ich besonnenheit klarheit und kompetenz
dass es derzeit gefragt und keine
sprücheklopfer wright so kann man kein
land regieren und deswegen haben wir als
koalitionsparteien am wochenende ein
drittes ein umfangreiches entlastungs
paket auf den weg gebracht kraftvoll und
gerechten und wie die beiden anderen
koalitions fraktionen auch haben wir uns
in der sommerpause inhaltlich damit
beschäftigt wir haben nicht jeden tag
ein neues thema durch die medien
getrieben zumindest haben wir auch keine
vorschläge zur körperhygiene hier
hinterlassen sondern wir haben ein
kraftvolles papier in dresden
beschlossen was für uns wichtig gewesen
war für diejenigen die für uns
verhandelt haben auch im
koalitionsausschuss durchzusetzen und
deswegen kommt es jetzt in den nächsten
wochen darauf an so schnell wie möglich
diese beschlüsse in die tat umzusetzen
und da wo nachbesserungen gebraucht
werden wird meine fraktion dafür auch
das notwendige tun lieber kolleginnen
und kollegen
und ja in der tat
das bedeutet mehr als nur ein paar
stellschrauben zu drehen
es bedeutet auch ein
systematisches eingreifen in das was
immer wieder behauptet wird und was
sozusagen im geheimen im verborgenen
funktioniert nämlich die geheimen kräfte
des marktes da waren wir schon beim
wohnungsmarkt wir sozialdemokraten
sozialdemokraten anderer meinung gewesen
als wir uns für die mietpreis bremse
eingesetzt haben und genau so ist es
jetzt für den strommarkt es ist richtig
dass wir den europäischen weg gehen aber
gleichzeitig wenn europa nicht die kraft
aufbringt dann werden wir hier wie
andere länder in der europäischen union
ungerechtfertigte gewinne vom strommarkt
abschöpfen und ja wir wollen
vergleichbares auch für die anderen
teile des wärme auf den weg bringen wir
bieten unsere fachlichkeit auch für
diese arbeitsgruppe an die sich für die
nächsten wochen auch weitere vorschläge
für diesen markt überlegen wird und
meine damen und herren auch bei diesem
entlastungspaket geht es eben nicht um
almosen wie manchmal behauptet wird
sondern für uns sozialdemokraten
sozialdemokraten das war immer tief
verankert in unserer seele in unserer
programmatischen bekenntnis wir wollen
keine almosen wir wollen soziale rechte
die am ende auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger einklagen können und deswegen
schaffen wir ein neues bürgergeld meine
damen und herren und wir schaffen eben
auch die ausweitung für eine
wohngeldreform die es verdient auch
dafür einzutreten und zum schluss bin
ich darauf hinweisen ja es ist doch
nicht falsch menschen dies unmittelbar
brauchen auch konkret zu entlasten und
auch das haben wir im dritten
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
rentnerinnen und rentner studierende
diejenigen schülerinnen und schüler die
bisher davon nicht profitiert haben die
fachschüler und die auszubilden und das
ist wichtig und dass das noch in diesem
jahr kommt dafür stehen wir ein und
dafür ist auch gut vorgesorgt dass in
diesem haushalt das finanziert werden
kann
und ja liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist auch eine vorausschau ein angebot
an andere institutionen und akteure in
diesem land gemacht wurden die sich
nicht verstecken dürfen in dieser krise
und auch das ist etwas was die dna der
sozialdemokratie betrifft wir wollen
alle dass sie ihren beitrag leisten und
der staat geht jetzt durch diesen
beschluss auch in vorleistungen und ich
appelliere an die tarifvertragsparteien
an die unternehmen geben
sie den arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer sicherheit wir geben die
sicherheit dass 3000 euro im jahr ein
abgaben und steuerfrei sind und das ist
ein gutes angebot in dieser krise meine
damen und herren wir wollen die freiheit
der menschen vor furcht und lud das ist
unser auftrag und unser streben zugleich
vielen dank
rolf mützenich der
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd in einer
angenehmen und ihren zurückhaltenden art
als die meisten seiner vorredner er hat
gesagt besonnenheit kleid und kompetenz
ist gefragt und keine sprücheklopferei
damit kann man nicht regieren sagte er
in richtung der cdu und in richtung von
friedrich merz
der nächste redner jetzt hier timo
kubala partei und fraktionschefs der
spd an hört da kann man wirklich sagen
ein esel nennt den anderen langohr das
ist ihre diskussion und ihre
streitkultur hier
deutschland aktuell verändert sich in
rasender geschwindigkeit ehemals das
wirtschaftliche aushängeschild in europa
sind wir auf dem besten weg vom geber
zum empfänger lang zu werden der
furchtbare umstand ist ukraine krieg
zerreißt europa von deutschland befindet
sich in einer neuen dauerhaften
abhängigkeit zu den usa und über die
wirklichen ursachen ja stolz haben sie
kein einziges wort verloren mittels
eines weitreichenden wirtschaftlichen
sanktionsregime gegen russland werden
die uns stück für stück isolieren und
die handlungsmöglichkeiten
einschränken der von robert habeck
angezettelte wirtschaftskrieg auf basis
dieser sanktion schadet deutschland
unseren bürgern aber nicht russland
anstelle der ukraine krieg
schnellstmöglich beenden zu wollen
liefert die bundesregierung weiter
schwere waffen anstelle auf allen
diplomatischen wegen zwischen russland
und der ukraine zu vermitteln zb mit
einer friedenskonferenz hier in berlin
wird medial immer wieder ins feuer
gegossen anstelle deeskalierend zu
wirken möchte die bundesregierung ihre
ideologien durchsetzen ergebnis russland
hat die lieferung von erdgas über nord
stream 1 eingestellt bis die sanktionen
aufgehoben sind da muss man wirklich
fragen macht sich das eigentlich nicht
nachdenklich stehen hier die 1 sitzt
mittel und die ergebnisse noch in einem
verhältnis das deutschland nutzt fragen
sich dass russland sei kein
zuverlässiger partner mehr hat
bundeskanzler stolz gesagt herr
bundeskanzler auch partnerschaften
müssen gepflegt werden und hätten sie
alle hier wirklich geglaubt hätten sie
hier alle wirklich geglaubt dass
russland diese sanktionen demütig
entgegennimmt auch stellt sich die frage
unserer zuverlässigkeit haben wir in die
langfristigen förderverträge
aufgekündigt welche fördermengen warum
eigentlich bestellt gas oder öl wurden
die abgenommen was haben wir eigentlich
bezahlt fragen über fragen die
bundesregierung nicht beantwortet die
bundesregierung treibt in dieser
situation siegesgewiss die energiewende
munter voran haben wir heute gehört ohne
rücksicht darauf die bürger im eigenen
land zu verlieren denn das ziel der
energiewende ist gescheitert
beziehungsweise war nie erreichbar da
erstens ein energieträger durch einen
anderen ersetzt werden sollte zweitens
wir weiter auf fossile energieträger
oder kernenergie angewiesen sind im
übrigen hätten wir hier herr merz in
diesem bundestag eine mehrheit die
kernenergie weiter zu betreiben und
drittens
fragen sie weiter dazu bei dass der
energiewende auch weiter wächst
politische ziele maßnahmen die
digitalisierung elektromobilität um den
ausstoß von co2 zu reduzieren oder jetzt
die glorifizierung der luft wärme pumpe
zeigen dass sie sich stets ausweise mit
problemlösungen beschäftigen ich frage
sie leider sarah engels weg kennen sie
sich wirklich so schlecht aus oder es
sich einfach nur egal wie unsere bürger
ihr leben bestreiten sollen aber das
haben sie ja gestern auch eindrucksvoll
abends bewiesen und da muss man sich
wirklich fragen habe ich sie an von
wirtschaft wirklich so viel ahnung wie
ein blinder von farbe
und lassen sie mich mal kunst darstellen
warum bald viele wohnungen und häuser
kalt bleiben was meinen sie wie wird
eine luftwärmepumpe endlich angetrieben
da möchte ich in ein klassisches
beispiel geben damit wir mal die
wirklichen zahlen sehen ein energetisch
saniertes haus ein einfamilienhaus 250
quadratmeter eine fünfköpfige familie
bezahlt im jahr 2021 gas bei einem
verbrauch von 24.000 kw bei einem vw
preis von 5,4 cent von 1470 euro aktuell
muss diese familie bei gleichem
verbrauch und 30 cent die kilowattstunde
7370 euro gas bezahlen + 6
grund das rohgas umlagert von 580 euro
sind
7950 euro
das ist die fast 47 fachen des
energiepreises und nutzen auch keine 200
oder 300 euro almosen war es liebe
freunde
und wenn ich jetzt auf die wärmepumpe
gehe kann ich jetzt auf die wärmepumpe
geben von habe kehre das allheilmittel
dann würde dieses haus zwischen 8.000
und 10.000 kw verbrauchen weil eine
wärmepumpe nati strom braucht beim
aktuellen kilowattstundenpreis von strom
von 63 cent würde das bedeuten
6400 euro mit der wärmepumpe aber herr
habe ich müsste natürlich den
energieanbieter immergrün nehmen das ist
ja eigentlich in den leuten auch
schuldig dort beträgt der
kilowattstundenpreis 1 euro können sie
alle nachschauen das würde bedeuten
10.000 euro stromkosten für dieses haus
und daran zerplatzt ihre grüne ideologie
allein an diesem rechenbeispiel einfach
mal nachrechnen
und wo wir gerade bei den bestehenden
häusern sind oftmals müssten die sie
auch komplett saniert werden damit diese
heizt dem jedoch überhaupt funktionieren
aktuell haben wir 32 millionen wohnungen
also knapp 80 prozent die älter als 30
jahre sind die da in frage kommen die
diese umrüsten müssten auch
fußbodenheizung dämme und
belüftungssysteme damit überhaupt eine
fußbodenheizung eine wärmepumpe
funktioniert es kann natürlich auch sein
muss man wirklich sagen dass die
bundesregierung auch hier wieder einen
plan in der tasche hat nach 19 grad im
wohnzimmer dem waschlappen haben wir
schon gehört einmal duschen pro woche
kommt vielleicht noch die staatlich
verordneten wollsocken dazu nach der
masken pflicht also hier sieht man diese
unglaubliche ideologie der
bundesregierung und das eigentlich
unglaubliche an dieser wahren geschichte
sie wird auch noch staatlich gefördert
werde die bundesregierung sie befinden
sich nicht in einem planspiel politik
was sie hier betreiben wird zur bitteren
realität für alle bürger und unternehmen
und sie verhöhnen alle die tagtäglich
zur wertschöpfung beitragen
[Applaus]
denn ihre vorschläge sie tragen nicht es
kann natürlich auch daran liegen dass
sich kaum jemand in ihren reihen mit
machbarkeit überhaupt noch
auseinandersetzt wasser kommt aus der
leitung strom kommt aus der steckdose
das ist ihre politik setzen sie doch zur
abwechslung mal mich war mit den leuten
zusammen die von technik ahnung haben
wie diese technik verbauen das sind die
handwerker die können ihre zauberhaften
geschichten aus ihren kinderbüchern in
die lebenswirklichkeit umsetzen und
sollten sie denn in deutschland noch
einen handwerker finden der in den
nächsten jahren noch heute wahltermine
hat wäre das sicherlich gut sollte sie
dann auch noch das baumaterial verfügen
weil die lieferketten die sie zerstört
haben noch vorhanden sind wäre es noch
besser allerdings sorgen sie mit ihrer
wirtschafts und bildungspolitik seit
jahrzehnten dafür dass es bald keinen
mittelstand mehr geben wird erdrückt
unter der enormen abgaben nass gegängelt
durch zertifizierung der europäischen
union sorgt ihre desaströse energiewende
politik endgültig für den tod vieler
praxen und es hat bereits leider
begonnen sie sehen wir haben es hier mit
dem ausverkauf unserer interessen zu tun
die bundesregierung steht sich selbst
und unserem land im wege und glauben sie
wirklich dass die menschen nicht
erkennen wer sie hier für spielchen
treiben es geht hier um den wohlstand
gehen unsere eltern den unsere
großeltern erarbeitet haben um wohlstand
und vor allem auch um werte die über
generationen in den familien gewachsen
sind grüne ideologen zerstören alles in
windeseile und das verheerende ist dass
die ehemalige mittelstands und
handwerker partei fdp hier auch noch
beifall klatscht sie sind genauso
gescheitert liebe bürger sie bekommen
von dieser bundesregierung keine
ehrlichen alternativen angebot die
politik dieser ampel koalition erklärt
immer zuerst was ist nicht mehr geben
darf als notwendig wird sanktioniert um
den eigenen willen durchzusetzen oder
sogenannten freunden zu gefallen die
ampel regierung verliert den
gesamtzusammenhang vollkommen aus dem
blick sie betreibt flickschusterei mit
dem ergebnis dass wir mehr und mehr
unseres wirtschaftlichen wohlstandes
verlieren die milliardenschweren
rettungspakete mit denen sie hier
erfolge ihrer regierungspolitik
verkaufen wollen haben die menschen da
draußen alle hart erwirtschaftet
vergessen sie das bitte nicht und alles
was dem deutschen vielleicht gefällt
oder nicht mehr gefällt das werden sie
jetzt auch auf der straße kundtun dürfen
und das ist ihr grundrecht auf die
straße zu gehen um zu demonstrieren dass
ist das was jedem bürger frei steht
[Applaus]
und deshalb zum abschluss wir brauchen
weiterhin russisches gas um eine
grundlastfähige reform des
energiesektors zu verwirklichen und
darin und darin sind sich der sächsische
ministerpräsident michael kretschmer und
die alternative für deutschland einig
deshalb hat bundeskanzler schaffen sie
tatsachen und machen sie schluss mit den
wirtschaftskrieg in russland wir
brauchen eine interessengeleitete
außenpolitik für deutschland und den
kontinent europa vielen dank
der bundestag ist in der aussprache der
generaldebatte am mittwoch in der
haushaltswoche und der nächste redner
kommt von den bündnisgrünen
andreas fritsch er stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
der etat des kanzleramtes es ist auch
der kultur etat und gerade nach der rede
die wir hier von herrn group angehört
haben kann es glaube ich nicht
eindrücklicher sein dass wir uns
klarmachen müssen dass wir über die
freiheit von kultur dass wir über
meinungsfreiheit und dass wir auch über
desinformation reden müssen sie von der
afg sind steigbügelhalter für die
russische propaganda sie machen das auf
den marktplätzen und sie machen das hier
im parlament herr kubala sie waren 2020
im dezember schon in moskau haben sich
von herrn norden lassen und genau diese
linie die produzieren sie hier im
deutschen bundestag und frau weil bei
ihnen ist es nicht besser sie haben
gerade eines getan hier im deutschen
bundestag sie haben die propaganda die
von russischen namen accounts im twitter
gestreut wurde gegen die deutsche
außenministerin eins zu eins wörtlich
hier ins hohe haus in den bundestag
getrag das ist nicht nur schäbig dass es
gefährlich und deswegen ist eines völlig
klar wir werden mit aller kraft die wir
aufbringen können dagegen halten und das
unterbinden und das tun wir das tun wir
nicht alleine sondern das tun wir mit
vielen kultur und medienschaffenden
journalistin journalisten aus russland
aus der ukraine
und deswegen bin ich froh dass wir ein
programm aufgelegt haben in höhe von
sechs millionen euro die das menschen
journalistin journalisten aus der
ukraine aus russland die hierher kommen
unterstützt damit sie weiter machen
können sie dass sie weiter dagegen
arbeiten können dass gerade jetzt in
zeiten in denen die freiheit in frage
steht in denen die meinungsfreiheit in
frage steht und autoritäres gedankengut
um sich greift dass diese stimmen der
freiheit dann nicht verstummen
und wir haben weitere sechs millionen
zusätzlich für die deutsche welle
eingestellt und an dieser stelle greifen
die außenpolitik unserer außenministerin
annalena baerbock und die kulturpolitik
von claudia roth gehen hand in hand und
greifen ineinander die klare kante gegen
tut ihnen die heißt auch dass wir eine
klare kante gegen desinformation und
gegenpropaganda haben und deswegen ist
richtig dass diese sechs millionen euro
in die ausweitung des angebotes auf
ukrainisch und auf russisch gehen wir
werden nicht zulassen dass
desinformation raum greift wir gehen
international und in deutschland gegen
wladimir putin und gegen auf propaganda
von ihnen mit aller härte vor
es gibt
eine zweite ebene der auseinandersetzung
putins gas krieg gegen deutschland und
europa wird gerade für viele
kulturschaffenden besonders hart werden
das sind menschen die bereits sich durch
zwei corona winter gequält haben die
noch nicht wissen wie der nächste winter
wird wie corona sich weiterentwickelt
und die jetzt beobachten müssen das
wegen der steigenden preise die
angesichts der fossilen inflation die
von putin gezielt auf den weg gebracht
wurde ihre
produktionen ihre theater schwer zu
finanzieren sind ausgerechnet der
bereich der in unserer gesellschaft
kritisch ist die leute die da sind wenn
es darum geht dass informationen
aufzudecken diese menschen in den
theatern in den bibliotheken in den
produktionsfirmen die stehen jetzt unter
druck mich haben in den vergangenen
wochen sehr viele hilferufe erreicht aus
dieser szene und ich kann ihnen sagen
wir sehen diese probleme wir nehmen die
auf und deswegen haben wir auch am
letzten wochenende genau diese frage bei
den verhandlungen im kanzleramt
adressiert im sonderform des bundes für
kulturveranstaltungen sind restmittel
vorhanden und der deutsche kulturrat hat
berechnet dass dort etwa eine milliarde
euro noch zur verfügung steht ich freue
mich sehr dass dieses geld nun nicht an
dem finanzminister zurück fließt sondern
dass es investiert wird dass es da
investiert wird wo es jetzt gebraucht
wird bei den kulturschaffenden die in
dieser zeit eine so wichtige rolle für
die meinungsfreiheit für den diskurs in
unserem land spielen und ich freue mich
sehr dass der deutsche kulturrat
angekündigt hat dass er vorschläge
machen will dass er mit offensiv in die
debatte gehen will wie wir das jetzt
schaffen über den winter lassen sie uns
kräfte bündeln lassen sie uns gemeinsam
gute ideen zusammen nehmen lassen sie
uns das geld nehmen und das bestmögliche
tun dass über den winter alle die im
kulturbetrieb unterwegs sind alle die an
der stelle dafür sorgen dass wir
klarheit haben in der debatte dass wir
wissen und das wie kritisch sind wenn
die propaganda wieder kommt ob von
russland über oder mittelbar von ihnen
von der afc dass wir diese menschen
schützen und dass wir diesen menschen
unterstützen die dort stehen und die
diese arbeit für uns machen es werden
schwierige verhandlungen werden wie
immer es an der stelle nicht genug geld
da wie wir insgesamt die frage haben wie
wir im winter die notwendigen fragen
investieren aber ich kann ihnen eine
sache sagen die eine milliarde die steht
jetzt zur verfügung wir gehen mit den
kulturinstitutionen ins gespräch und wir
werden lösungen finden das alle die die
in der kulturbranche unterwegs sind
unsere unterstützung dabei haben gut
durch diesen winter zu kommen herzlichen
dank
der kollege otto fricke ist auf dem weg
zu uns zu sprechen für die fdp fraktion
auch präsidentin meine lieben kollegen
klingen zur kultur komme ich gleich
nochmal kollege spiel aber auch
hinweisen noch steht die milliarden
nicht zur verfügung noch muss dieses
parlament beraten noch müssen wir das im
haushaltsausschuss klären und dann
müssen wir aber sehr sehr genau gucken
und das ist gerade bei der kultur
milliarde so wichtig wie wir zielgenau
an der stelle helfen denn das wird für
den einzelnen kultur schafft eine ganz
große aufgabe sein und ich sage das auch
für alle die jetzt hier zuhören und
zuschauen ja es gibt im kulturbereich
bedenken ob das im winter wieder geht ob
man zu allen veranstaltungen gehen kann
oder nicht aber bitte überlegen sie an
der stelle auch dass jedes mal wenn ich
es mir bequem machen und sagen ich
verzichte auf kultur dann zerstöre ich
auch ein teil von kultur weil nicht die
möglichkeit besteht dass ein
kulturschaffender eine kulturschaffende
ihre kreativität auch an den menschen an
die bürgerinnen an den mitbürger bringen
kann das wird eine wichtige aufgabe in
der kulturpolitik im herbst im winter
dann auch sein meine damen und herren
zum haushalt die schuldenbremse wird
eingehalten das war etwas wo viele
gesagt haben das geht nicht das ist aber
nicht nur ein zeichen von einem
angeblichen fetisch oder irgendetwas das
sage ich auch in richtung linke das ist
freilich eine verfassung das ist eine
verfassung die wir einheiten und eine
verfassung als fetisch zu bezeichnen
finde ich schon sehr sehr bemerkenswert
war das zeigt ihr verständnis vom
grundgesetz doch sehr sehr deutlich
meine damen und herren das zweite ist
wir halten das auch deswegen ein weil
wir ein zeichen nach europa und in die
welt geben dass dieser staat versucht
auch über die rettungspakete zu helfen
wo er kann wo er muss aber gleichzeitig
immer im auge hat das ja das dauerhaft
tun will seine leistungsfähigkeit
erhalten will an spätere generationen
denken dieses zeichen müssen wir auch
geben denn woran liegt denn die unruhe
die wir alle verspüren nicht nur bei uns
sondern auch in unserem freundeskreis
bei bekannten bei familie bei menschen
die der arbeit sind sie liegt auch daran
dass wir nicht klar wissen wie diese
zukunft gelaufen sind wird das weiß hier
übrigens keiner genau und deswegen
versuchen wir mit diesem haushalt und
mit diesen rettungspaketen dafür zu
sorgen dass wir reagieren können und ich
glaube es ein sehr gutes drittes
entlastungspaket mit dem wir in den
herbst in die verhandlungen und dann bis
zum 10 november auch in ein
haushaltsgesetz 2023 gehen können
herzlichen dank dafür an die verhandler
übrigens kleiner an merkel ich freue
mich auch sehr dass die
koalitionsparteien in dem papier auch
noch mal deutlich rein geschrieben haben
dass die schuldenbremse auch in den
haushaltsberatungen gilt und auch das
ist ein teil dessen was wir uns für die
nächsten wochen und monate klar vor
augen halten dürfen dennoch komme ich
auch heute wieder zu der leeren bank es
war heute ein ministerpräsident da ich
glaube das lag weniger an der debatte
hier sondern mehr daran dass es ein
sommerfest in nrw gibt aber stellen wir
das dann mal hin dann war der da als der
oppositionsführer geredet hat dann waren
da als der bundeskanzler gerät hat und
als die afg gericht hat und als der
koalitionspartner liebe grüne aus nrw
geredet dann ist er gegangen würde ich
mir auch mal überlegen was das dann
eigentlich an der stelle zeigt ist zeigt
aber etwas anderes die länder haben
immer noch nicht verstanden was in einem
föderalen staat in dem sie mehr
steuereinnahmen haben als der bund vom
uhr mit ali mehr steuereinnahmen als
bunt was ihre aufgabe ist und wenn sie
dann sagen ja die haben ja so viel
belastungen zu bestimmen war nicht sagen
dass man 2021 der bund hatten
finanzierungssaldo von minus 130
milliarden
dieses jahr geplant 117 die länder
hatten im letzten jahr ein
finanzierungssaldo von wissen sie es -
nein es war plus die länder hatten ein
plus im letzten jahr wir machen
verschuldung um zu helfen und die länder
sagen da haben wir ganz wenig mit zu tun
und wenn der bund ein angebot macht für
ein gutes entwicklung wir wollen und wir
müssen bessere pnv haben dann sagen die
länder ist ja nettes angebot aber wir
reden doch nochmal darüber dass sie
einen mehr zeit für dinge wo wir
zuständig sind und dann immer dieses
jahr aber die länder haben sowie
verwaltungsaufgaben und das dann sage
ich ihnen ehrlich wenn sie sagen dass
sie die länder gegen den bund aufnehmen
wollen beim land das stimmt sind viele
verwaltungsaufgaben viele
personalausgaben aber die sozialausgaben
das sollten sie als linke viel viel
besser wissen die liegen beim bund und
wenn ich abwägen muss als liberaler mit
meiner fraktion und mit dieser koalition
zwischen verwaltungsausgaben und
sozialausgaben dann weiß ich auf welcher
seite diese koalition steht meine damen
und herren deswegen sage ich auch in
anlehnung an den alten probensatz
knowtech station für station man kann
das aus sicht der länder auch mal anders
sagen nur wer kann mit entscheiden der
auch mit zahlt entsprechend seiner
verfassungsrechtlichen verantwortung und
da setze ich auf den bundeskanzler der
ja mal ministerpräsident weiß und weiß
welche klebrigen fingern da kommen denn
das wird für die verhandlungen glaube
ich bei uns noch sehr sehr schwierig
werden wie die auswirkungen dessen was
die ministerpräsidenten wollen auf
diesen haushalt werden wird zum schluss
ich will das mal persönlich versuchen zu
sagen weil romeo und julia es im dritten
akt dritte szene du kannst von dem was
du nicht willst nicht reden und eines
hat doch diese debatte gezeigten das
sollten wir als demokraten den bürgern
doch damit deutlich machen wir fühlen
was das für probleme sind wir sehen was
das für probleme sind und das sage ich
gehe genauso auch für die cdu ich weiß
es nicht ob es sie für die beiden
extremen parteien geht aber wir fühlen
was die mitbürger betrifft und wir
versuchen die möglichst beste lösen und
darüber streiten wir nicht darüber wird
schlecht oder böse ist herzlichen dank
otto fricke der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion er hat es
angesprochen die bundesbank auch beim
heute bei der heutigen debatte
lea die ministerpräsidenten außerdem
nordrhein-westfälischen der sich ohnehin
in berlin befunden hatte heute ich hier
nicht aber sie sind gefragt denn sie
müssen für das nachfolgeteam geht es
neun euro tickets jahr selber noch geld
geben das wird sicherlich noch
verhandlungen geben kerstin radomski
jetzt für die cdu/csu
dass ein ministerpräsident seine
klebrige finger verliert wenn er
bundeskanzler wird halte ich für steil
aber wir können ja mal schauen ob das
tatsächlich so ist lieber otto bei den
haushaltsberatungen über den etat des
bundes kampf lars möchte ich aber als
erstes mal auf den bereich kultur
eingehen nachdem die bundesregierung nun
neun monate arbeitet muss man sagen jede
regierung hat ihre herausforderungen das
ist so und ich möchte jetzt nicht auf
die debatte zur documenta die wir in den
medien verfolgen konnten eingehen das
macht meine kollegin schenderlein gleich
aber ich möchte doch auf einige
kürzungen in die im etat kultur eingehen
wo man sich als opposition zu recht
fragen kann wie kam es dazu die der
beitrag an die stiftung preußischer
kulturbesitz ist um 12 millionen euro
gekürzt und vielleicht bald können sie
uns gleich eine antwort darauf geben wie
es kam und dann wenn ich noch über eine
zeige stolpert in der letzten debatte
zum haushalt hatten wir hier eine
diskussion auch mit kurzintervention wo
es um eine kürzung beim humboldt-forum
ging und da gab es doch tatsächlich die
these dass da gekürzt wurde weil man mit
wissenschaftlichen beschriftungen an den
exponaten nicht zufrieden ist und jetzt
stelle ich fest
diese kürzung haben sie nicht
zurückgenommen frau
kulturstaatsministerin und da stellt
sich mir und meiner fraktion dann auch
die frage
halten sie es genauso wie in dieser
kurzintervention mit dieser anmerkung
dass man beim humboldt-forum kürzen muss
weil die wissenschaftlichen beschriftung
nicht richtig sind wir kritisieren zudem
dass sie mit zweierlei maß messen und
bei ihnen erinnerungskultur nicht
überall gleich behandelt wird die
aufarbeitung der kolonialgeschichte ist
wichtig aber auch die ansätze der
gedenkstätte deutscher widerstand und
stiftung aufarbeitung sed werden gekürzt
und da fragt man sich schon ob es diese
themenfelder für sie nicht die bedeutung
haben wie für uns als unionsfraktion
und
leider ist ihnen auch das thema
vertriebene weniger wert obwohl flucht
und vertreibung in diesen monaten
aktueller denn seit langer zeit sind
nachdem der ansatz für vertriebene im
letzten haushalt gekürzt wurde sinkt er
nun um erneut um eine million euro das
ist definitiv eine fehlentscheidung aus
meiner sicht
stattdessen
investieren sie in ihr lieblingsprojekt
wie in culture
das teilt es auf über 15 millionen euro
erhöhten ansatzes für die nachhaltigkeit
ist und ich habe jetzt gehört dass die
ampel koalition viele hilferufe der
filmindustrie erreichen dabei ist
festzustellen dass genau diese branche
die gebeutelte deutsche filmwirtschaft
durch das green shooting finanziell
belastet wird ich zitiere den
geschäftsführer björn böhning bis vor
kurzem noch beamteter staatssekretär in
ihrer bundesregierung der st die
aktuelle kostenentwicklung in der
produktions branche in deutschland ist
alarmierend bei der umsätze von
nachhaltigkeitsstandards die zunehmend
verpflichtet werden gehen wir von
zusätzlichen kosten von bis zu fünf
prozent aus zitat ende naja wenn man das
möchte dann muss das natürlich auch
irgend jemand bezahlen und dann finde
ich es schon erstaunlich dass man dann
von hilferufen aus der filmwirtschaft
spricht aber ich kann an dieser stelle
nur an die ampel appellieren meine damen
und herren bitte überfrachten sie die
kreativen in unserem land nicht noch
weiter mit zusätzlichen regeln und
maßgaben neben dem bereich kultur möchte
ich noch einen kurzen blick auf den
geplanten erweiterungsbau des kanzlers
werfen das bundesinnenministerium
prognostizierte doch tatsächlich dass
die kosten auf mindestens 600 millionen
euro statt der veranschlagten
485 millionen euro steigen könnten und
der bundesrechnungshof geht sogar davon
aus dass es noch teurer wird
oppositionsfraktion und als neue
berichterstatterin in diesem einzelplan
frage ich schon seit längerer zeit nach
einem berichterstatter gespräch zu dem
thema in den letzten haushaltsberatungen
war das nicht möglich ich danke aber
nach intensiven einsätzen von otto
fricke dass wir dann morgen endlich ein
gespräch zu dem thema kanzleramt haben
werden ich hoffe für alle parlamentarier
an dieser stelle das nicht schon fakten
geschaffen wurden die dann das parlament
zu ende tragen muss deshalb meine zeit
leicht heißt leider nicht um auf den
ostbeauftragten und die
integrationsbeauftragte einzugehen die
aufwand anwesend sind aber ich hoffe auf
intensive gespräche in den
parlamentarischen beratungen und wünsche
uns dabei allen viel erfolg vielen dank
das gfk hat das wort für die
spd-fraktion
frau präsidentin herr bundeskanzler
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren seit
sechs monaten für putins russland einen
verbrecherischen krieg gegen die ukraine
und gerade jetzt wenn die auswirkungen
dieses krieges immer größere
herausforderungen für die menschen in
deutschland auch für unsere
volkswirtschaft mit sich bringen ist
unseren debatten eines voranzustellen
die ukraine hat in ihrem freiheitskampf
gegen den russischen adresse unsere
volle unterstützung so lange wie sie
diese unterstützung braucht
putin führt diesen krieg nicht nur auf
den schlachtfeldern er führt ihn auch am
gashahn und mittels des informationen
setzen mit all dem ziel darauf ab die
demokratie in dieser welt zu schwächen
und zu spalten doch das werden wir nicht
zulassen
putin dorf und putin wird diesen krieg
nicht gewinnen das ist und bleibt die
erste prämisse der zeitenwende unseres
bundeskanzlers
deswegen tun wir in der ampelkoalition
alles um uns aus der abhängigkeit von
russischer energie zu befreien wir lösen
die bremse beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien sie sind der schlüssel zu einer
klimaneutralen welt aber eben auch der
schlüssel für unsere souveränität
wir sorgen so zuverlässig die
gaslieferungen aus alternativen quellen
wir treffen vorsorge durch massive
einspeicherung wir nehmen
kohlekraftwerke wieder in betrieb und
der belassen zwei da noch in betrieb
befindlichen atomkraftwerke über das
jahresende hinaus in der reserve ganz
klar ist aber auch ein nochmaliger
ausstieg aus dem atomausstieg ist mit
uns nicht zu machen
die atomkraft ist eine
hochrisikotechnologie in sie produziert
auf jahrtausende strahlen atommüll denen
wir nicht sicher sagen können und
deshalb war der atomausstieg vor 22
jahren hat der übrigens stattgefunden
und wurde beschlossen die völlig
richtige entscheidung der regierung von
spd und grünen
zu dieser überzeugung ist nach einer
beispiellosen licht 3 11 jahre später
auch die damals regierende koalition
unter führung der cdu gekommen eine
richterin herr merz der nun das
parlament leider verlassen hat die
deutsche steuerzahler vertragsstrafen in
milliarden-höhe gekostet hat wir haben
das nicht vergessen haben als sie
offenbar schon
was sie auch gar nicht vergessen würden
märz noch im frühjahr es ist schon öfter
gesagt worden forderten sie ein
sofortiges gas im auge für eine kleine
populistische schlagzeile waren sie
damals bereit die energieversorgungen
damit auch die industrielle produktion
in deutschland in die wand zu fahren
ganz ehrlich von der größten
oppositionspartei hier im parlament
erwarte ich ein bisschen mehr
ernsthaftigkeit wenn es darum geht die
grösste krise zu meistern und die dieses
land zumal sondern
ich sage aber auch ganz deutlich der
jetzt fordert nord stream zwei in
betrieb zu nehmen der den eindruck
vermittelt mit der rückkehr in die arme
die mir putins sei unsere
energieversorgung zu sichern oder die
inflation zu bekämpfen
der spielt dem russischen aggressor
direkt in die hände